Hey gang, it's Monday, for me, and maybe for you it's Tuesday, or Wednesday, or possibly Thursday, obviously Friday or Saturday or something. It could be Monday, or Mardi, Mardi, Jeudi, Pantredi, Samedi, Dimanche, those are the days that we can French, Abbi. So, bienvenue, c'est smetless. Smart, wise. Smart, wise. Smart, wise.
嘿伙计们，对我来说今天是周一，对你们来说可能是周二、周三，或者可能是周四，当然也可能是周五、周六之类的。可能是周一，或者 Mardi, Mardi, Jeudi, Pantredi, Samedi, Dimanche，这些是我们能用法语说的日子，Abbi。所以，欢迎，这是 SmartLess。聪明，睿智。聪明，睿智。聪明，睿智。
Sean, did you make, did you end up making a spare on that last frame? Because I've also noticed. Listener, Sean's got a pinky splint on, and it looks like a half a bowling card. Are you still wearing the boot on your foot, too? No, no, the boot on my foot. And he's also texting while we're asking these questions. Do you want to hold the records before you're done with your social media? No, I'm looking for a video of me golfing.
肖恩，你上一局最后补中了吗？因为我也注意到了。听众们，肖恩的小指上戴着夹板，看起来像半个保龄球护具。你脚上还穿着那只靴子吗？不，不，我脚上没穿靴子。而且我们在问这些问题时，他还在发短信。在你忙完社交媒体之前，你想先拿着记录吗？不，我在找一段我打高尔夫球的视频。
I want to show you guys my golf swing. What is the pinky hammock for? What's going on? Okay, so I just have a little tenonitis in my right pinky. No, you don't. How does one even identify tenonitis in a pinky? You don't have anything. You didn't have a foot thing.
我想给你们看看我的高尔夫挥杆。那个小指吊带是干什么用的？怎么回事？好吧，我右小指有点肌腱炎。不，你没有。一个人怎么能确定小指得了肌腱炎？你什么事都没有。你脚也没事。
You don't have a fucking tenonitis in your thing. Take it off, shut up, and keep going. What are you talking about? No, just from playing. I'm trying to play. Did you get that? How do you injure your pinky? Is that from like a remote control that was unwieldy or?
你根本就没有什么该死的肌腱炎。把它摘了，闭嘴，继续。你在说什么？不，就是打球打的。我正试着打球。你听到了吗？你怎么会伤到小指？是因为遥控器太笨重了吗，还是？
No. No, it's playing piano, just like the same piece over and over and over. What's happening is I'm reaching too far with my pinky. So it's totally fine now. It's a piano injury, is that right? I kept playing with the same piece and then I replaced my piece. And now I have a more like a permanent... You just zipped that one on, right?
不。不，是弹钢琴，就是同一首曲子弹了一遍又一遍。发生的情况是我弹的时候小指伸得太远了。所以现在完全没事了。是钢琴造成的伤害，对吧？我一直弹同一首曲子，然后我换了曲子。现在我有了更像永久性的……你刚才把那个拉链拉上了，对吧？
Oh, it's a zipped in the back. There's no snap in the front, zipped in the back. It's pretty great. So Sean, this is playing piano, rehearsing for your upcoming Broadway show. Called. Starting. Let's get the dates out.
哦，它是背后的拉链。前面没有按扣，背后有拉链。这很棒。所以肖恩，这是在弹钢琴，为你即将上演的百老汇演出排练。叫什么来着。开始。我们把日期定下来吧。
And the theater and all that stuff was a website or something like that. It's called Good Night Oscar. Performances start April 7th in New York at the Belasco Theater. And you can buy tickets at something.com. Can I say? Can I say? You know what? After I talked to a friend, that was Oscar LeVette,
还有剧院什么的，是个网站之类的。它叫《晚安，奥斯卡》。演出将于4月7日在纽约的贝拉斯科剧院开始。你可以在某个网站买票。我能说吗？我能说吗？你知道吗？在我和一个朋友谈过之后，那是奥斯卡·勒维特，
just as I remembered him. What a great compliment. We can say that. We can talk about that if you want. Let's do it. Let's open it up. Go ahead, Sean. We're not going to open up.
就像我记忆中的他一样。多好的赞美啊。我们可以说。如果你愿意，我们可以谈谈这个。来吧。让我们开始吧。说吧，肖恩。我们不会开始的。
Okay. It's up to you guys. I don't care. No, it's up to you. We, first of all, we love you. And I will say we did try to come in the, I know we're talking about Good Night Oscar again, but we did try to come in the spring and then we couldn't.
好吧。由你们决定。我不在乎。不，由你们决定。首先，我们爱你。而且我要说，我们确实试着在……我知道我们又在谈论《晚安，奥斯卡》了，但我们确实试着在春天去，但没去成。
You tried it real hard. You know, why didn't we go? I was working on the weekends. And then during the week, you didn't want to. No, I mean, I was working during the week, but I was also working Saturdays. And you were back. What was I doing?
你们真的很努力。你知道，我们为什么没去？我周末在工作。然后在工作日，你不想去。不，我的意思是，我在工作日工作，但我周六也工作。而你回来了。我在做什么？
Everybody was working. Why didn't I go? Maybe I think you were just feeling so bullish about it going to Broadway eventually that we were just like, well, let's just keep our powder dry for New York. But also, like, I'm not one of those people. I don't think you guys are too. It's like, you got to come see my show.
每个人都在工作。我为什么没去？也许我觉得你当时对它最终能上百老汇感到非常乐观，所以我们就像，好吧，让我们为纽约保留实力吧。但还有，就像，我不是那种人。我不觉得你们也是。就像，你一定要来看我的演出。
No, no, no. Or you got to go see my movie. Yeah. You know, I'm just like, come or don't come. I don't expect anyone to, even if it's in the convenience of your own home on television, I don't expect you to watch. No, I've had the thing before actually where I've said, like to like, you know, my mama said like,
不，不，不。或者你一定要去看我的电影。是的。你知道，我只是觉得，来或者不来都行。我不指望任何人，即使是在你自己家里看电视，我也不指望你一定要看。不，我以前确实有过那种情况，我说，就像，你知道，我妈妈说，
why don't you tell us that you're on Kimmel? I'm like, what am I going to do? I don't want to. Yeah. Send out a newsletter. Yeah. Yeah. No.
为什么你不告诉我们你在吉米·坎摩尔的节目上？我说，我能做什么？我不想。是的。发个通讯。是的。是的。不。
Yeah. You know, you'll see about it. You'll see about it on social media when people are, you know, ready. Got white pants on today? Well, okay. Oh, white shorts. Oh, white shorts.
是的。你知道，当人们准备好的时候，你会在社交媒体上看到的。今天穿白裤子？好吧，好的。哦，白短裤。哦，白短裤。
Oh, no. I'm wearing white shorts. No, no, no. Don't, don't, don't spread them. Uh-oh. Ew, and white slides. What's going? Do you have a yacht party?
哦，不。我穿着白短裤。不，不，不。别，别，别把它们撑开。哎呀。呃，还有白色拖鞋。怎么了？你有游艇派对吗？
I've got these. I see them. Wait. Those are Air Jordan slippers? Slides. Yeah. Oh, slides. Oh.
我有这些。我看到了。等等。那是Air Jordan拖鞋？凉拖。是的。哦，凉拖。哦。
What's the difference between a slide and a slipper? I'm wearing these. These shorts are so comfy and they're like a terry short. You know. Oh my God. You know. Stop with that. Don't ever say that again.
凉拖和拖鞋有什么区别？我穿着这些。这些短裤太舒服了，它们是毛圈布短裤。你知道的。哦，天哪。你知道的。别再说了。永远别再那样说了。
So it's terry. You know what I would love? I'd love for you to just put that dumb outfit on thinking, ew. Oh, ew. We just, I just saw top pubes. He just showed us the waistband, listener,
所以是毛圈布。你知道我想要什么吗？我真希望你穿上那套蠢衣服，心想，呃。哦，呃。我们刚才，我刚才看到了阴毛，他刚才给我们看了腰带，听众们，
and the shorts were down a little bit lower than his ideal. So they, I'd love for you to go to just get in the car. Oh, I got to go get some milk down at the liquor store or something. Not, not expecting to be out really out about, and then get a flat tire and be stuck on the side of the road
而且短裤比他理想的位置低了一点。所以它们，我真希望你只是去上车。哦，我得去酒铺买点牛奶什么的。没打算真的出门，然后爆胎了，被困在路边，
with traffic going by in that outfit. But wait a minute. Wait a minute. That's what Scotty always says to me. He's like, I go, I'm just going to the 7-Eleven to get some ice cream. He's like,
穿着那套衣服，车流从旁边经过。但等一下。等一下。那是斯科蒂总是对我说的。他说，我去，我只是去7-Eleven买点冰淇淋。他说，
like that. Just like you're getting a flat. And, but, but look at you, I get that from you. You're like, I like,
就像那样。就像你爆胎了一样。而且，但是，但是看看你，我从你那里得到了那个。你就像，我喜欢，
but I will not leave the house with my, with my Birkenstocks on that have the, the, the fuzz on the inside, the furries. I would totally do that. Those are slippers. I would totally do that.
但我不会穿着我的勃肯鞋出门，里面有那种绒毛，毛茸茸的。我绝对会那样做。那是拖鞋。我绝对会那样做。
I'd never be seen in public. You know what, you know what, actually it's funny that you say that because I have, I wear my slippers often to drive the kids to school and whatever, and they have a tread on the bottom. And the reason I felt okay doing that was because about
我永远不会在公共场合露面。你知道吗，你知道吗，其实你说这个很有趣，因为我经常穿着拖鞋开车送孩子们上学什么的，它们鞋底有防滑纹。我之所以觉得这样做没问题，是因为大约
15 years ago, I went to jar with Scotty and Sean, and Sean showed up at dinner wearing slippers for dinner. Oh, for dinner day. We, we,
15年前，我和斯科蒂还有肖恩一起去吃饭，肖恩穿着拖鞋去吃晚餐。哦，为了晚餐那天。我们，我们，
we pulling the little, a stand with your, with your, with my IV. Yeah. That's it. He, he had claimed it that time though.
我们拉着那个小架子，带着你的，带着我的静脉注射。是的。就是这样。不过他当时声称是那样。
He kept saying, I hope I die soon. I hope. So I guess he had given up in that moment. No, I had, I had Ugg slippers, which could,
他一直说，我希望我快点死。我希望。所以我猜他在那一刻已经放弃了。不，我有，我有UGG拖鞋，这可以，
you know, he did have slippers. Oh, so they're dressed up. Remember Richard Ehrlich? Remember that time when I first met him and he was at your old house and he came and he was wearing Uggs. And I go, Hey man.
你知道，他确实有拖鞋。哦，所以它们是盛装打扮。还记得理查德·埃利希吗？还记得我第一次见到他的时候吗？他在你旧房子里，他来了，穿着UGG。我说，嘿，伙计。
And I never met him before I go. Hey, hey, Kate Hudson called. She really wants her boots back. Now, can't make anything look good. Let's hold on a second now.
我以前从没见过他，我说。嘿，嘿，凯特·哈德森打电话来了。她真的很想拿回她的靴子。现在，什么都穿不出好效果。等一下。
Kate, Kate, make anything look good. Oh, I agree. Start any trend. And by the way, Ehrlich can make anything look good. Ehrlich,
凯特，凯特，什么都能穿出好效果。哦，我同意。引领任何潮流。顺便说一句，埃利希什么都能穿出好效果。埃利希，
let me tell you something. A guy is good looking when you can pull off a turtleneck. His hair is phenomenal. That's one of the best. You know who else, you know who else can turn, can pull up a turtleneck?
我告诉你一件事。一个男人穿高领毛衣好看，那才叫帅。他的头发太棒了。那是最好的之一。你知道还有谁，你知道还有谁能穿，能穿高领毛衣吗？
Sean Levy. Sean Levy can also pull up. Sean Levy. Yeah, that's a great point. Yeah. A great comment of yours. Not a lot of guys can wear
肖恩·利维。肖恩·利维也能穿。肖恩·利维。是的，说得好。是的，你评论得很好。没多少人能穿
the white territory shorts though. No, Touched snatter for champion. I told you, I never to say that again. Touched snatter for champion. I know you like that. Here come the boxes.
白色毛圈布短裤。不，Todd Snyder for Champion。我告诉过你，永远别再那样说了。Todd Snyder for Champion。我知道你喜欢那个。盒子来了。
A couple of words, Can we get to the guests, please? The fourth thing. Our guest, by the way, It's not your guest, it's Sean's, isn't it?
几句话，我们能请嘉宾了吗？第四件事。顺便说一句，我们的嘉宾，这不是你的嘉宾，是肖恩的，对吧？
It's my guest, I won't Hold on a second. Let me sit up a little bit taller then. Oh, because my guests aren't from my guests, you don't have to
这是我的嘉宾，我不会……等一下。那我坐直一点。哦，因为我的嘉宾不是来自我的嘉宾，你不需要
on all of this, especially when it comes to fashion and our fashion, and you know what? My guest has complimented me before, and I don't know if they remember. I'll give it to you, she remembers, but she has. But I will say this, she doesn't need to because she's got a lot going on for her. She's a recipient of many awards.
在所有这些事情上，特别是在时尚和我们的时尚方面，你知道吗？我的嘉宾以前夸过我，我不知道他们记不记得。我会给你的，她记得，但她确实夸过。但我会说这个，她不需要，因为她有很多成就。她是许多奖项的获得者。
Or she has shitty tasting in men's clothing, I can tell you. Okay, I can't wait for you to chase that think bar with your own fucking words, dude. Because guess what? This is Stella McCartney. This is a real class act. This is a top of the line actor. This is somebody who has done it all.
或者她对男装的品味很烂，我可以告诉你。好吧，我等不及让你用你自己的该死的话来追回那句话了，伙计。因为你猜怎么着？这是斯特拉·麦卡特尼。这是一个真正的顶级演员。这是一个顶级演员。这是一个做过一切的人。
Who's won the awards, who's done the action films, who's done the horror scary films, who's done the big drama films, that get all the fancy awards. This is the red carpet stalwart. This is somebody who is not only incredibly brilliant and smart and funny and engaging and beautiful and cool and also happens to be married
赢过奖项的，演过动作片的，演过恐怖惊悚片的，演过那些获得所有华丽奖项的大型剧情片的。这是红毯上的常客。这是一个不仅极其聪明、睿智、有趣、迷人、美丽、酷，而且恰好嫁给了
to a very good friend of ours. It's the one and only Ms. Emily Blunt. Emily! Oh, this is perfect. It's a nice Saturday morning. It's just smoothed in there. I love your shorts. Thank you. Don't say Terry again.
我们一位非常好的朋友的人。她就是独一无二的艾米丽·布朗特女士。艾米丽！哦，这太完美了。这是一个美好的周六早晨。它就这样顺滑地进来了。我喜欢你的短裤。谢谢。别再提毛圈布了。
Thank you, there's Terry. No, you got me with Terry, I was all in with Terry. And you know what, it's because you've got- Don't interrupt her, she's talking. Go ahead, sorry. You have a great suntan and that helps, you know? Thank you very much. Thank you, I do, thank you.
谢谢，那是毛圈布。不，你用毛圈布抓住了我，我完全沉浸在毛圈布里了。你知道吗，这是因为你有……别打断她，她在说话。继续，抱歉。你晒得很好，这有帮助，你知道吗？非常感谢。谢谢，我确实，谢谢。
You can, you get a tube of what he's got, you can rub one on yourself, you know? It's all bronzer. Excuse me? Body bronzer. First of all, excuse me? Emily, I love that you called it suntan as opposed to a bed tan,
你可以，你弄到一管他有的那种，你可以自己涂一点，你知道吗？全是古铜色乳液。你说什么？身体古铜乳。首先，你说什么？艾米丽，我喜欢你称它为晒黑，而不是日光浴床晒黑，
because I think his tan is from a bed, right? It's a tube tan. First of all, I'm sorry. Is it a tube tan? What is the brand of the bronzer that you use? Of course, fucking not, it's not a, you think that I can go to a goddamn suntan salon? No, you wouldn't waste that time.
因为我觉得他的肤色是来自日光浴床，对吧？那是管装晒黑。首先，我很抱歉。那是管装晒黑吗？你用的古铜乳是什么牌子的？当然，该死的不是，它不是一个……你以为我能去该死的日光浴沙龙吗？不，你不会浪费那个时间。
You just take out the tube of the bronzer and just squirt on a bronzer. No, no, no, no, no. What am I, Trump? No, no, no, no. Emily, Emily, good morning. Hi, Emily. Hi, guys, how are you?
你只是拿出那管古铜乳，然后挤在身上。不，不，不，不，不。我是特朗普吗？不，不，不，不。艾米丽，艾米丽，早上好。嗨，艾米丽。嗨，伙计们，你们好吗？
This is so long overdue. You know what's even longer overdue? What? John, now we gotta talk about why hasn't John been on the show yet? Well, one of us is gonna get in a lot of trouble the day he does show up. I know, it's true.
这太迟了。你知道什么更迟吗？什么？约翰，现在我们得谈谈为什么约翰还没上过这个节目？好吧，我们其中一个人在他出现的那天会惹上大麻烦。我知道，这是真的。
He's gonna be hot. Hell, Tracy. He's gonna be, he's gonna come in swinging. He's gonna come in very hot. And he's gonna come in with a ton of emotions. He's gonna come in with a lot of emotion. You might not even say yes now that Emily's been on first.
他会很火大。见鬼，特雷西。他会，他会气势汹汹地来。他会非常火大地来。而且他会带着一堆情绪来。他会带着很多情绪来。既然艾米丽先来了，你可能甚至不会说愿意了。
And we're 150 episodes into this same, oh yeah. Hey, Tracy, just so you know, we're talking about John Krasinski. I'm sure you know that they're married. The John Krasinski. That's right. The John Krasinski. Emily Blunt.
而且我们已经录了150集了，哦，是的。嘿，特雷西，你要知道，我们在谈论约翰·卡拉辛斯基。我相信你知道他们结婚了。那个约翰·卡拉辛斯基。没错。那个约翰·卡拉辛斯基。艾米丽·布朗特。
Yeah. Hi, period. Hi. You know what, it's like, you know what? You know what's funny? I just, I think about how great you are at everything you do. And then when I get sent from our producer,
是的。嗨，句号。嗨。你知道吗，就像，你知道吗？你知道什么很有趣吗？我只是，我想着你在你所做的一切事情上是多么出色。然后当我从我们的制片人那里收到
all this stuff, and I go like, my God, Emily's done so much cool shit and so much good stuff. And you kind of forget because you're so, you do it also kind of effortlessly and elegantly. And you wear it all so well. And you're not like, you're not into self promotion. You're not a braggart.
所有这些东西时，我就想，天哪，艾米丽做了这么多酷事和这么多好事。你有点忘记了，因为你做得太轻松、太优雅了。而且你穿得都很好。而且你不是那种，你不是那种热衷于自我推销的人。你不是一个吹牛的人。
You're not kind of like looking for action. You just kind of do it. And you just kind of, and it just falls off. You wear it real loosely. Wait, are you saying you're not on snap? Are you not on snap? Is it a verb now? It's just, it's like.
你不是那种在寻找行动的人。你只是做了。然后你只是，它就这样掉下来了。你穿得很随意。等等，你是说你不在Snap上吗？你不在Snap上吗？这是一个动词吗？它只是，它就像。
Yeah, I'm snapping. I'm snapping. And I'm gramming. Guys, I don't snap. And I don't gram. I don't snap. I don't gram either. I do lurk.
是的，我在Snap。我在Snap。我在Gram。伙计们，我不Snap。我也不Gram。我不Snap。我也不Gram。我确实潜水。
I mean, I do lurk on the gram. Okay, you do. I do a little bit of a lurk, yeah. Emily Blunt, I've been such a fan for such a long time and I've always wanted to meet you. And so this is really cool. Wait, you guys don't know each other? No, we've never met.
我的意思是，我确实在Gram上潜水。好吧，你确实。我确实潜水了一点，是的。艾米丽·布朗特，我一直是你的粉丝，很久了，我一直想见你。所以这真的很酷。等等，你们不认识彼此吗？不，我们从没见过。
No, we've never met. I'm so excited to meet you two. Will, let's take a quick five and let them get acquainted. Yeah, so I have, I've been like, you've been on my list as well as to be a guest on this show. Yes, I remember we were gonna do the live one.
不，我们从没见过。我很高兴见到你们俩。威尔，让我们休息五分钟，让他们熟悉一下。是的，所以我一直，你也在我的名单上，作为这个节目的嘉宾。是的，我记得我们要录现场版。
And then we got together. Oh, is that what happened? Yeah, you were on. You had asked me to do, you had asked me before these jackasses and I didn't even know you. We're gonna do it right, right, right. You didn't even know you.
然后我们聚在一起。哦，是那样吗？是的，你在上面。你在这些混蛋之前就问过我，我甚至都不认识你。我们会做好的，对，对，对。你甚至都不认识你。
So I'm such a fan. Oh, wait till, wait till John, his brother's full. Let me tell you something about Krazz. But Krazz is... He's tough to book. You know, the guys are busy. Tough to book.
所以我真是个粉丝。哦，等着，等着约翰，他兄弟满了。让我告诉你一些关于Krazz的事。但Krazz是……他很难预约。你知道，这家伙很忙。很难预约。
He's tough to nail down. So like, you text him and then he's like, and then he takes two weeks and then he texts you and then he's like, what? Question mark, you're like, hey man, I don't get 30 seconds and then you got two weeks?
他很难确定下来。所以就像，你给他发短信，然后他就像，然后他花了两周时间，然后他给你发短信，然后他就像，什么？问号，你就像，嘿伙计，我没得到30秒，然后你有两周时间？
Yeah. Yeah, you guys are gonna have to really duke this one out, I think. I know. God bless him. Anyway, did you guys, do you guys know Emily really well? Because of John, right?
是的。是的，我想你们得真的好好打一架了。我知道。上帝保佑他。总之，你们，你们很了解艾米丽吗？因为约翰，对吧？
Yeah. Well, I mean, that's how we've heard of her. You guys were some of the first people that I ever met in Los Angeles. You were, I think you guys were literally the first friends of his. And then you immediately moved out of city. What was that?
是的。嗯，我的意思是，这就是我们听说她的方式。你们是我在洛杉矶见过的第一批人。你们是，我想你们真的是他第一批朋友。然后你们立刻搬出了城市。那是怎么回事？
Would you have stayed? We just ran. Yeah. I mean, I mean, me before Jason, obviously I introduced Jason to Crat. I feel like I'm at the center of like a weird axis. Yeah. So how did you meet, you met John via whom?
你会留下来吗？我们只是跑了。是的。我的意思是，我的意思是，在杰森之前，显然我把杰森介绍给了Crat。我觉得我处于一个奇怪轴心的中心。是的。所以你是怎么认识的，你是通过谁认识约翰的？
Amy? Will. Yes, yes. And we met. So you have some sort of office slash parks and everything? John and I met at Mike Shure's wedding. Got it. Okay, so Mike knew Amy from SNL.
艾米？威尔。是的，是的。我们见面了。所以你们有什么办公室之类的公园和一切？约翰和我在迈克·舒尔的婚礼上认识的。明白了。好吧，所以迈克从SNL认识艾米。
Okay, got it all. And I knew Mike and we were at the wedding and then John and I ended up dancing a lot together. And I know it sounds terrible, but we did. Wait, John danced? This is unusual for John to dance at a wedding. You must have had some kind of good hands. It was terrible dancing.
好吧，全明白了。我认识迈克，我们在婚礼上，然后约翰和我最后一起跳了很多舞。我知道这听起来很糟糕，但我们确实跳了。等等，约翰跳舞？这对约翰来说在婚礼上跳舞很不寻常。你一定有什么好手。那是糟糕的舞蹈。
It was a lot of just like jumping around more than anything. I think I saw some photos of that recently. Anyway, we became friends. Then these guys started dating and we became friends. And immediately, Sean, here's one of the things that I don't know if you can feel it already with yourself. You immediately fall in love with Emily. She's incredible.
那更多的是像跳来跳去，而不是别的。我想我最近看到了一些照片。总之，我们成了朋友。然后这些家伙开始约会，我们成了朋友。而且立刻，肖恩，这是我不知道你是否已经能感觉到的一件事。你立刻爱上了艾米丽。她太不可思议了。
Well, I didn't have to meet her to fall in love with her, but now that I have. I know, I know. But Emily, I wanna know like what's the, cause I would love to get to know you and this is the perfect opportunity. What is the, what brought you over to America first? I'm obviously assuming you grew up in the UK.
嗯，我不需要见到她就能爱上她，但现在我已经见到了。我知道，我知道。但艾米丽，我想知道，就像，因为我很想了解你，这是一个绝佳的机会。是什么，是什么把你带到美国的？我显然假设你在英国长大。
Do you mean the, what, job? Yeah, did you used to visit or was it a job that brought you here? I mean, I know we went to Disney. Is it Disney World in Florida or Disney Land? Yeah, Disney World, yeah. So we did that when I was a kid and that was about it until I started, you know,
你是说，什么，工作？是的，你是以前来过，还是工作把你带到这里的？我的意思是，我知道我们去了迪士尼。是佛罗里达的迪士尼世界还是迪士尼乐园？是的，迪士尼世界，是的。所以我在小时候做过那个，在那之后就没怎么做过，直到我开始，你知道，
trying to come over and audition for stuff and came over for the terrifying pilot season. I remember seeing it back in the day. Did you? And then, what's that? You came over for pilot season? Yes. How old were you?
试着过来试镜，然后为了可怕的试播季过来。我记得以前看过。你看了吗？然后，那是什么？你为了试播季过来的？是的。你多大了？
And I didn't look anything. How old were you? I was about 19. I think. Wow. Were you with mom, were you with mom and dad or are you just solo? No, I just, I was alone.
而且我看起来一点也不像。你多大了？我大约19岁。我想。哇。你是和爸爸妈妈在一起，还是独自一人？不，我只是，我是一个人。
Actually, I was with my ex-boyfriend. Yeah. And we stayed at the Beverly Hills Motor Hotel. Yeah. Oh boy. That means you just get to park in a spot there and they plug you into cable and stuff like that. But then there was that really cool diner downstairs.
其实，我是和我的前男友在一起。是的。我们住在比佛利山庄汽车旅馆。是的。哦，男孩。这意味着你只是在那里停个车位，他们把你插进有线电视之类的东西里。但楼下有个很酷的餐馆。
It was an amazing diner. Yeah. I can't remember what it was called. Do you remember any of the shows that you auditioned for that pilot season that ended up going to series that you didn't get? No, I have no memory because it was so terrifying. It's all such a blur that whole time.
那是个很棒的餐馆。是的。我不记得它叫什么了。你还记得那个试播季你试镜的任何最终成剧的节目吗？不，我没有记忆，因为它太可怕了。那段时间的一切都很模糊。
So I don't know if you remember anything. So after pilot season, you would just go back home to England or? Then I would go back home to England and then I did this little independent film in England called My Summer of Love. It was my first movie. And then I did sort of, then I got an American agent
所以我不知道你是否记得什么。所以试播季之后，你就回英国了还是？然后我就回英国了，然后我在英国拍了一部小独立电影叫《我爱夏日长》。那是我的第一部电影。然后我做了某种，然后我找了一个美国经纪人
and then I came back out again and I auditioned for Devil Wears Prada, you know, quite early on. Which I just watched again like a week ago, of course you did. That was the thing that changed stuff. That did. Was that your second movie? It was my third movie.
然后我又回来了，我试镜了《穿普拉达的女王》，你知道，很早的时候。我一周前刚又看了一遍，当然你看了。那是改变一切的事情。确实。那是你的第二部电影吗？那是我的第三部电影。
Oh my God. Yeah, I mean, I just went ahead and crushed it. I've watched that so many times. Yeah, you've done like a mini series and stuff. You've done like a film made for television, right? And then you've done that film, My Summer of Love. And then you did My Devil Wears Prada. And this was a film that had Meryl Streep
哦，天哪。是的，我的意思是，我只是继续并摧毁了它。我看过很多次了。是的，你拍过迷你剧之类的。你拍过电视电影，对吧？然后你拍了那部电影，《我爱夏日长》。然后你拍了《穿普拉达的女王》。这是一部有梅丽尔·斯特里普
and Anne Hathaway who was just kind of coming out as this new young star. And you, Sean, threw, you just like there was like this thing. Everybody was like, who is that girl? Yeah. Did you feel everything change the moment that film came out? Could you feel it like, oh, things are different? Yeah, it was, I did feel it was almost overnight.
和安妮·海瑟薇的电影，她当时刚作为这个新的年轻明星出现。而你，肖恩，扔，你只是就像有这个东西。每个人都在说，那个女孩是谁？是的。那部电影出来的那一刻，你感觉到一切都变了吗？你能感觉到吗，哦，事情不同了？是的，它是，我确实感觉到几乎是一夜之间。
Things changed. It was quite dramatic. I remember I was in LA and I was staying actually with the producer of The Devil Wears Prada. I was staying in her guest house for free if I just would babysit her kids. And I would go to the same bakery. I would go to the same bakery every day in Beverly Hills.
事情变了。这相当戏剧性。我记得我在洛杉矶，我其实住在《穿普拉达的女王》的制片人家里。我免费住在她的客房里，只要我帮她照看孩子。我会去同一家面包店。我每天都会去比佛利山庄的同一家面包店。
And then after the weekend it came out, but people sort of knew who I was. That's amazing. And the character's name was Emily. Was that changed or was that just a coincidence? That was just in the script. That was just in the script. But she was written and the audition for it was
然后周末过后它出来了，但人们有点知道我是谁了。这太神奇了。而且角色的名字叫艾米丽。那是改了还是只是巧合？那就在剧本里。那就在剧本里。但她被写了，而且试镜是
was mad and maybe it's why I got it because I felt so chaotic in the room. I was reading for something else. I think it was like a dragon flying movie. It was like before Game of Thrones. It was like a dragon movie happening. I can't remember what the name of it was. And I was auditioning for that and I was desperate to get it.
是疯狂的，也许这就是我得到它的原因，因为我在房间里感觉太混乱了。我在读别的东西。我想那是一部像龙飞行的电影。那是在《权力的游戏》之前。那就像一部龙电影正在发生。我不记得它的名字是什么了。我当时在为那个试镜，我非常渴望得到它。
And then they said that she, hey, you know, we got this other movie and will you read for it quickly? And they just sort of handed me the pages. And I remember I was rushing to catch my flight and I was so scared of being late for the plane that I think I read the audition in a kind of chaotic way. And maybe that worked. And then I remember being back in London
然后他们说，嘿，你知道，我们有另一部电影，你愿意快速读一下吗？他们只是把页面递给我。我记得我正赶着去赶飞机，我太害怕迟到赶不上飞机了，我想我以一种混乱的方式读了试镜。也许那奏效了。然后我记得回到伦敦
in a nightclub with my sister. And I got a call from the director. And I mean, he must have just been like, should I hire this person? Because it was just like, you know. And he was like, Emily, it's David Frankl. It was so cool. And then you got the part.
在一家夜总会和我姐姐在一起。我接到了导演的电话。我的意思是，他一定只是想，我应该雇这个人吗？因为这就像，你知道。他说，艾米丽，我是大卫·弗兰克尔。这太酷了。然后你得到了那个角色。
That's so cool. Yeah. Well, actually, I had to go and audition again. But he said, I would cast you the studio like you. But because I looked like a mess in the audition before I was wearing like a t-shirt and jeans. He went, can you go and put on something more fashionable, you know, so they can see you in the role?
这太酷了。是的。好吧，其实，我不得不再次试镜。但他说了，我会选你，工作室喜欢你。但因为我在之前的试镜中看起来很乱，我穿着T恤和牛仔裤。他说，你能去穿点更时尚的东西吗，你知道，这样他们就能在角色中看到你？
Really, really? Yeah. You were dressed for the Dragon film. Yeah, so I read again. But isn't that funny that you're about to do, you read for that and it feels like overnight when it comes out and you say it feels like overnight. And meanwhile, you want to be like, guys,
真的，真的吗？是的，所以我又读了一遍。但你不觉得有趣吗，你正要去做，你读了那个，当它出来时感觉就像一夜之间，你说感觉就像一夜之间。与此同时，你想说，伙计们，
I was here staying at the motor in when I was 19. This is not, I've been fucking paying my goddamn dues. And then people are like. But even so, it was quick, right? I mean, the success. And you have, how can you, is it, I'm sure you've attributed it to your mom or your dad, but can you give an easy explanation
我19岁时就住在这里的汽车旅馆。这不是，我一直在该死地付我的会费。然后人们就像。但即便如此，它很快，对吧？我的意思是，成功。而且你有，你怎么能，是吗，我相信你把它归功于你的妈妈或爸爸，但你能给出一个简单的解释吗
for how you've been able to be so elegantly unjaded and conceded with the massive success you had so fast? Don't attribute it to your member dad either, just to just to dissuade him from ever again and putting words in your mouth. You blame it on your dog. Your dogs kept you humble. Well, I mean, it was all such a great surprise to me
关于你是如何能够如此优雅地不厌倦，并以你如此快速获得的巨大成功而自满的？别把它归功于你的成员爸爸，只是为了劝阻他再次把话塞进你的嘴里。你把它归咎于你的狗。你的狗让你保持谦逊。好吧，我的意思是，这一切对我来说都是一个巨大的惊喜
when it actually did happen. I went into the industry without a burning desire to do it, which I think actors sometimes hate to hear. And your dad was a lawyer, right? Wasn't that right? Yeah, my dad defends criminals for a living still. My mom was an actress and then had way too many children. And had a hard time within the business.
当它真的发生时。我进入这个行业时并没有强烈的愿望去做它，我想演员有时讨厌听到这个。你爸爸是律师，对吧？不是吗？是的，我爸爸现在仍然以辩护罪犯为生。我妈妈是演员，然后生了太多孩子。而且在生意中过得很艰难。
So I didn't have any sort of preconceived idea that it would be a sunny time. I think I'd seen it be quite painful for my own mom. And so I did a school play, got an agent because he came to see the play and he said, you want to give it a go. So maybe me going in with quite a casual attitude was good because I didn't expect anything.
所以我没有任何先入为主的想法，认为那会是一段阳光明媚的时光。我想我见过它对我自己的妈妈来说相当痛苦。所以我演了一部学校戏剧，找了一个经纪人，因为他来看了那部戏，他说，你想试一试吗。所以也许我以一种相当随意的态度进入是好的，因为我没期待任何事情。
I don't know if it's also, if you're from England, it's so abhorrent if you enthuse readily about yourself. It is so embarrassing to sort of self-promote or self-aggrandize, so it's part of it is sort of cultural. And yeah, I don't know. That's interesting, yeah. Yeah, you do have, well, that's what I mean, but you wear it so loosely, like, you know,
我不知道这是否也是，如果你来自英国，如果你轻易地对你自己充满热情，那是令人厌恶的。自我推销或自我夸大是如此令人尴尬，所以部分原因是文化上的。而且是的，我不知道。这很有趣，是的。是的，你确实有，嗯，这就是我的意思，但你穿得太随意了，就像，你知道，
that you're just so sort of... Like a drapey terry shirt. Like a moomoo. Well, these aren't drapey. These are quite... Don't stand up again. Don't, no, you can sit down. OK.
你只是如此某种……就像一件垂坠的毛圈布衬衫。就像一件穆穆长袍。嗯，这些不是垂坠的。这些相当……别再站起来了。别，不，你可以坐下。好的。
Who makes those? Is that James Purse? No, thank you for asking. It's Todd Snyder for champion. Um, it makes Jason so crazy when I say a name for... James Purse is way too quality and classy to make a terry shirt. Oh, no, oh, really?
谁做的那些？那是James Purse吗？不，谢谢你的询问。是Todd Snyder for Champion。嗯，当我为一个名字说的时候，这让杰森变得如此疯狂……James Purse的质量和档次太高了，不会做毛圈布衬衫。哦，不，哦，真的吗？
I have James Purse, I have James Purse white terry shorts, fact, and I love them. Oh, gosh. Then I'll wear them, because if James Purse is making them, I'm wearing them. Yeah. OK, well, then you will be allowed. Emily, that, that right there,
我有James Purse，我有James Purse白色毛圈布短裤，事实，我喜欢它们。哦，天哪。那我会穿它们，因为如果James Purse在做它们，我就穿它们。是的。好的，好吧，那你就被允许了。艾米丽，那，就在那里，
Jason just betrayed a thing about him. I've long suspected it, but I haven't noticed due to very evasive measures, quote from Whitnell, because what he's done there is, unless it's been stamped OK by certain, as he likes to say, taste makers, it's not OK. He doesn't have the guts to take a fucking risk.
杰森刚才背叛了他的一件事。我早就怀疑了，但我没注意到，因为非常规避的措施，引用自Whitnell，因为他所做的是，除非它被某些，正如他喜欢说的，品味制造者盖章OK，它就不OK。他没有胆量去冒该死的风险。
I will not take risks. I won't, I won't do it. No. So he literally said to the guys from Radiohead... I won't even skip a step on a staircase. But you do take risks with your work. He said to the guys from Radiohead, I want to stamp my foot to it, but I can't.
我不会冒风险。我不会，我不会做。不。所以他真的对Radiohead的家伙们说……我甚至不会在楼梯上跳过一步。但你在工作中确实冒了风险。他对Radiohead的家伙们说，我想跟着它跺脚，但我不能。
But I know that I'm supposed to like the music. You're not supposed to like anything. I'm leaving this interview. I'm quitting this interview. Oh, guys, look at his hand hanging out. You take big swings with your work, though. Come on, we've got a hat. He might not take a big swing with a terry short,
但我知道我应该喜欢这音乐。你不应该喜欢任何东西。我要离开这次采访。我要退出这次采访。哦，伙计们，看他悬着的手。你在工作中确实有很大的动作。来吧，我们有一顶帽子。他可能不会在毛圈布短裤上有大动作，
but he takes big swings with what he agrees. Yeah, there he goes. Well, he's a very talented guy. I am not a fashion forward guy, but I am not risk averse. I will tell you that. We'll be right back. This episode of SmartLess is brought to you in part by GMC.
但他在他同意的事情上有大动作。是的，他去了。嗯，他是一个非常有才华的人。我不是一个时尚前卫的人，但我不是风险厌恶者。我会告诉你那一点。我们马上回来。这一集SmartLess部分由GMC赞助。
Hey, listeners, Will here. A few weeks ago, I had the privilege of seeing the all-electric GMC Sierra Denali EV Edition 1 firsthand. It is one of the perks of being the voice of GMC. So having experienced it in person, I've seen exactly why they call it the Denali of EVs. It's powered by Altium battery technology.
嘿，听众们，我是威尔。几周前，我有幸亲眼看到了全电动GMC Sierra Denali EV Edition 1。这是作为GMC代言人的福利之一。所以亲身体验过它，我看到了他们为什么称它为电动汽车中的Denali。它由Altium电池技术驱动。
It delivers incredible agility, power, and one of the things I love more than anything, capability. As for versatility, it has the new available multi-pro mid-gate that can fold down for the extra bed space and flexibility. So I have, again, seen this multi-pro mid-gate. It is so awesome because you can literally just extend the cargo bed of your truck
它提供了令人难以置信的敏捷性、动力，以及我最喜欢的东西之一，能力。至于多功能性，它有新的可用Multi-Pro中门，可以折叠起来以获得额外的床空间和灵活性。所以我再次看到了这个Multi-Pro中门。它太棒了，因为你可以字面上只是扩展你的卡车货床
and add this space from the inside of your truck. It's just incredible. I could go on and on, but I only have 60 seconds in this break. So go to GMC.com backslash Sierra EV and experience the Denali of EVs for yourself. The first ever GMC Sierra EV Denali Edition 1 available by reservation only in early 2024. Sierra EV Denali, available spring 2024.
并从你的卡车内部增加这个空间。这真是太不可思议了。我可以继续说下去，但我在这个休息时间只有60秒。所以去GMC.com斜杠Sierra EV，亲自体验电动汽车中的Denali。首款GMC Sierra EV Denali Edition 1仅在2024年初通过预订提供。Sierra EV Denali，2024年春季上市。
Hey, smart list listener, we get support from FanDuel. Football season is underway, so now is the perfect time to download FanDuel, America's number one sportsbook. Because right now, new customers get no sweat first bet, up to $1,000. So that's free bets back if your first bet doesn't win. Just sign up with promo code smart list. FanDuel has all your favorite bets from the money line
嘿，SmartLess听众，我们得到了FanDuel的支持。橄榄球赛季正在进行中，所以现在是下载美国第一体育博彩公司FanDuel的最佳时机。因为现在，新客户可以获得高达1000美元的无压力首注。所以如果你的第一笔投注没赢，会有免费投注返还。只需使用促销代码smartless注册。FanDuel有你所有喜欢的投注，从胜负盘
to point spreads to player props. And you can combine your bets for a chance at a bigger payout with the same game parlay. With live betting, you'll get updated odds on games that have already started. And the app is safe, secure, and super easy to use. Get your winnings paid fast. So sign up today with promo code smart list
到让分盘再到球员道具。你可以组合你的投注，有机会通过同场连赢获得更大的赔付。通过现场投注，你将获得已经开始的比赛的更新赔率。而且该应用程序安全、可靠，并且非常易于使用。让你的奖金快速支付。所以今天就用促销代码smartless注册
for your no sweat first bet. Make every moment more this season with FanDuel, official sportsbook partner of the NFL. 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer. Smart list is sponsored by BetterHelp. So I talked to you guys a lot about therapy. I think it's really important.
以获得你的无压力首注。这个赛季用FanDuel让每一刻都更多，NFL的官方体育博彩合作伙伴。21岁以上，排除条款适用。查看节目说明以获取完整免责声明。SmartLess由BetterHelp赞助。所以我经常和你们谈论治疗。我认为这真的很重要。
I think it's good to get it out. Because when it's bottled up, you're like a tea kettle. And you're just like, whoop, and you're going to explode. And it's not good. It's not good to keep it inside, because then it festers and it ruins other things inside your body, like your organs and your brain and stuff. Stress is not good.
我认为把它说出来很好。因为当它被装在瓶子里时，你就像一个茶壶。你就像，呼，你会爆炸。这不好。把它留在里面不好，因为它会溃烂，并破坏你体内的其他东西，比如你的器官和大脑之类的。压力不好。
You've got to talk to somebody. So unfortunately, life doesn't come with a user manual to help you to learn how to talk to somebody. So when it's not working for you, it's normal to feel stuck. Therapists are trained to help you figure out the cause of challenging emotions and learn productive coping skills, which makes therapy the closest thing to a guided tour
你必须和某人谈谈。所以不幸的是，生活并没有附带用户手册来帮助你学习如何与某人交谈。所以当它对你不奏效时，感到卡住是很正常的。治疗师受过培训，可以帮助你找出具有挑战性的情绪的原因，并学习富有成效的应对技能，这使得治疗成为最接近引导式旅游的东西
of the complex engine called you. As the world's largest therapy service, BetterHelp has matched 3 million people with professionally licensed and vetted therapists available 100% online. Plus, guess what? It's affordable. Just fill out a brief questionnaire
关于被称为你的复杂引擎。作为世界上最大的治疗服务，BetterHelp已经为300万人匹配了专业许可和审查的治疗师，100%在线提供。另外，你猜怎么着？它很实惠。只需填写一份简短的问卷
to match with a therapist. If things aren't clicking, you can easily switch to a new therapist anytime. It couldn't be simpler. No waiting rooms, no traffic, no endless searching for the right therapist. Learn more and save 10% off your first month at betterhelp.com slash smartless.
以匹配治疗师。如果事情没有点击，你可以随时轻松切换到新的治疗师。这再简单不过了。没有候诊室，没有交通，没有无休止地寻找合适的治疗师。在betterhelp.com斜杠smartless了解更多并节省你第一个月的10%。
That's better help H-E-L-P.com slash smartless. And now, back to the show. OK, I want to get to the, now you say big swings. So I want to talk about something that's a big swing and that we've talked, I've talked to you about it personally because I felt very strongly about this at the time and I feel even more strongly now, I think.
那是betterhelp H-E-L-P.com斜杠smartless。现在，回到节目。好的，我想进入，现在你说大动作。所以我想要谈论一些是大动作的事情，我们谈论过，我个人和你谈过，因为当时我对这一点感觉非常强烈，我想我现在感觉更强烈了。
Here we go. The Edge of Tomorrow, the film you did with Tom Cruise. You worked with so many big names. Hang on, Sean. It's one of my favorite movies. It is such an underrated film. An underrated film. You are so good in it.
开始了。明日边缘，你和汤姆·克鲁斯合作的那部电影。你和那么多大牌明星合作过。等等，肖恩。那是我最喜欢的电影之一。那真是一部被低估的电影。一部被低估的电影。你在里面演得太好了。
And I remember how hard you trained for it and all that stuff and going into it. But B, you're just so good in it. And the film itself is so fucking good and Tom Cruise is so good in that film as well. He's so brilliant in it. When does this one come out? Oh.
我还记得你为它做了多么艰苦的训练，以及所有那些准备工作。但是B，你在里面真的太棒了。这部电影本身也他妈的太棒了，汤姆·克鲁斯在片中也演得非常好。他在里面真是太出色了。这部电影是什么时候上映的？哦。
Oh. It did, by the way, Jason, have you seen it? I have heard that, no, I've heard that that's, it is the film, yeah. Wait, Jason, can we please watch it together? Yeah, get over here with your little pinky splint. And let's put it on. Emily, can you talk a little bit
哦。顺便说一下，杰森，你看过吗？我听说过，不，我听说那是，确实是那部电影，没错。等等，杰森，我们能一起看吗？好啊，带着你那根小指夹板过来吧。我们把它放出来看。艾米莉，你能稍微谈谈
about that experience of that film? Because it did, again, you trained so super hard. Didn't you injure yourself a couple of times? I did, I did. I still sort of have this injury that sustains from it. And I think, you know, because it was before I had kids, it was nine, 10 years ago we did it. And it was my first foray into action.
那部电影的拍摄经历吗？因为确实，再说一次，你训练得超级刻苦。你是不是还受了几次伤？是的，是的。我至今还有那种伤留下的后遗症。我想，你知道，因为那是在我有孩子之前，我们拍那部戏是九、十年前的事了。那是我第一次尝试动作片。
And as Tom said, rather unreassuringly, when we started, he goes, this is the deep end of action for me. And I was like, if you're saying that, like, we are in trouble, you know. What was the start, what was the... Well, we had to wear these really enormous robotic suits, which I think would have been great
正如汤姆所说，在我们开始时，他不太令人安心地说，对我来说，这是动作片的深水区。我就想，如果你都这么说，那我们就有麻烦了，你知道。那是怎么开始的，那是……嗯，我们必须穿上这些非常巨大的机器人套装，我想如果能用CGI制作的话会很棒，
if they could have CGI'd them, but we wanted to do it practically and in a tactile way. And you know, when you hear the word tactile, you're like, that sounds nice and cozy. Like, there was nothing cozy about wearing these suits. Like, mine was like 85 pounds. It was so heavy that the first time I put it on, I just started to cry, just started to cry in front of Tom.
但我们想以实拍和触觉的方式来完成。你知道，当你听到“触觉”这个词时，你会觉得，那听起来既舒适又惬意。但穿这些套装一点也不惬意。我的那套大约有85磅重。它太重了，我第一次穿上它时，就开始哭，就在汤姆面前哭了起来。
And he didn't know what to do. And he just stared at me. It was like, I know, I know. Yeah. And I was like, Tom, I'm not sure how I'm going to get through this shoot. And I started to cry. I was like, I'm just feeling a bit panicky
他不知道该怎么办。他只是盯着我看。就像是，我知道，我知道。是的。我说，汤姆，我不确定我该怎么熬过这次拍摄。我开始哭。我说，我只是觉得有点恐慌
about the whole shoot. And he literally goes, he stared at me for a long time, not knowing what to do. And he goes, come on, stop being such a pussy, okay? Yeah, nice. I love that. I love that for Tom. And I did laugh and then we got through it.
关于整个拍摄过程。他真的，他盯着我看了很久，不知道该怎么办。然后他说，得了吧，别像个胆小鬼一样，好吗？是的，不错。我喜欢这个。我喜欢汤姆这一点。我确实笑了，然后我们熬过来了。
But the training was intense. It was like twice a day we trained for it. But I got injured doing a stunt. We called it the beach. It was a sort of big sort of beach set that we did the big battles on. And I had to do this aerial stunt on wires. And I was supposed to land on my shoulder
但训练非常紧张。我们每天训练两次。但我是在做一个特技时受伤的。我们称之为“海滩”。那是一个很大的海滩布景，我们在上面拍摄了大型战斗场面。我必须在钢丝上做一个空中特技。我本应该用肩膀着地，
and I landed on my face. And my legs kind of went whoop, like that. So it's just a kind of, well, I think I, it was my ribs and my collarbone, which still a bit dodge now. Thanks, Tom. Sean heard his fingers, he was pinky on a piano. I can see.
结果我脸着地了。我的腿就像那样“嗖”地一下。所以这只是一种，嗯，我想我，是我的肋骨和锁骨，现在还有点不对劲。谢谢你，汤姆。肖恩伤了他的手指，他是在弹钢琴时伤到小指的。我看得出来。
Yeah. Wait, I do need to know. Reaching for a G. Cause I heard. Reaching for a G. A G flat. G sharp. By the way, that's weird you say it cause it happened.
是的。等等，我确实需要知道。去够一个G音。因为我听说了。去够一个G音。一个降G音。升G音。顺便说一下，你说这个很奇怪，因为它确实发生了。
I swear to God it happened on a G sharp. Did it really happen on a G sharp? Yeah, it really did happen. Poor baby. Are you really wonderful at the piano? He's a concert, he's a trained concert pianist. Are you really? Yeah, yeah.
我发誓，它确实是在升G音上发生的。真的是在升G音上发生的吗？是的，确实是在升G音上发生的。可怜的宝贝。你真的很擅长弹钢琴吗？他是位音乐会钢琴家，受过专业训练的音乐会钢琴家。真的吗？是的，是的。
Oh, Emily, his show that's coming to Broadway next year, hang on, his show that's coming to Broadway next year, he plays the piano live. He plays all this incredible music on stage. It's incredible. Gershwin. Oh my God. Okay.
哦，艾米莉，他明年要在百老汇上演的节目，等等，他明年要在百老汇上演的节目，他现场弹钢琴。他在舞台上演奏所有这些不可思议的音乐。太不可思议了。格什温。天哪。好吧。
Well, we need it. We need to be friends. Sean's been trying to get a question for six minutes. Go ahead, Sean. Better be good. Go ahead. Cause I'm champing at the bet. Better be fucking great.
嗯，我们需要它。我们需要成为朋友。肖恩已经试图插话问一个问题六分钟了。说吧，肖恩。最好是个好问题。说吧。因为我正迫不及待呢。最好他妈的精彩点。
Go ahead. It's terrible. Colour, horoscope sign. You cut her off like three times to get this in. Go ahead. Oh my God. Look who's talking. I know.
说吧。太糟糕了。颜色，星座。你为了插话打断了她三次。说吧。天哪。看看是谁在说话。我知道。
Okay, so wait. I'm on fire. So on the screen, whenever I'm like going, cause Scottie and I bought like six, 700 movies that are our favorite movies, right? And so when we scroll down. How depressed do you want me to be? Like.
好吧，等等。我正兴头上呢。所以在大屏幕上，每当我像这样，因为斯科蒂和我买了大约六、七百部我们最喜欢的电影，对吧？所以当我们向下滚动时。你想让我有多沮丧？就像。
Okay, so when we scroll down. Do you each have your own individual popcorn bowl or do you guys share it? Oh my God, we totally share. We do a popcorn bowl. But okay, so on the like menu thing, it changes the poster for the edge of tomorrow changes. And they always put live, die, repeat.
好吧，当我们向下滚动时。你们每个人都有自己的爆米花碗，还是你们共享一个？天哪，我们完全是共享的。我们用一个爆米花碗。但是好吧，在那个菜单上，海报变了，《明日边缘》的海报变了。他们总是写着“生、死、重复”。
And so do people think that that's the name of the movie? Honestly, it's so frustrating. It has about five titles. Originally when I signed on, it was called all you need is kill, which I thought was pretty cool. Which is the name of the book that it's based on. It's a Japanese book.
所以人们以为那是电影的名字吗？老实说，这太令人沮丧了。它大约有五个标题。最初我签约时，它叫《杀戮轮回》，我觉得这很酷。也就是它改编的那本书的名字。那是一本日本书。
It's really cool. But I think live, die, repeat is pretty cool. Cause that's. Live, die, repeat is pretty cool. But I don't know. But then it got changed to edge of tomorrow, which I, to be honest with you, didn't like as much. I thought it sounded a bit like it.
真的很酷。但我认为“生、死、重复”也挺酷的。因为那是。“生、死、重复”挺酷的。但我不知道。但后来它被改成了《明日边缘》，老实说，我没那么喜欢。我觉得它听起来有点像。
I didn't love it either. It sounds like a soap opera. Yes. Whereas like live, die, repeat is great. Cause ultimately the film is just, you see the mileage you can get out of a repeating day. And it's really cool. Yeah.
我也不喜欢。它听起来像肥皂剧。是的。而“生、死、重复”很棒。因为归根结底，这部电影就是，你看到了重复的一天能带来的里程碑。这真的很酷。是的。
So did they end up calling it edge of tomorrow, colon, live, die, repeat for real? Yes. I don't even know. I mean, people say different things to me all the time. And I go, yes, it's one of those three titles. I feel like this was all Tom's fault. I feel Tom in a marketing meeting,
所以他们最终真的把它叫作《明日边缘：生、死、重复》了吗？是的。我甚至不知道。我的意思是，人们总是对我说不同的东西。我就说，是的，它是那三个标题之一。我觉得这全是汤姆的错。我感觉汤姆在营销会议上，
you know, up on a chair saying, no, no, no, guys, understand something. Hey, are you fucking crazy? He really didn't. He was, he was upset about it. If you are, you're crazy blaming Tom Cruise. He will hear about this. I'm not blaming him for anything,
你知道，站在椅子上说，不，不，不，伙计们，明白一点。嘿，你他妈疯了吗？他真的没有。他，他对此感到很不高兴。如果你是，那你指责汤姆·克鲁斯就疯了。他会听到这个的。我没有指责他任何事，
but pure success in some of the greatest movies we've ever seen. I love that. I love that guy. I love his. I remember Emily, when you were doing it, I kept asking you about Tom Cruise. Cause I remember Krazz and I were obsessed with him
除了纯粹的成功，在一些我们见过的最伟大的电影中。我喜欢这个。我喜欢那个家伙。我喜欢他的。我记得艾米莉，当你拍那部戏时，我一直问你关于汤姆·克鲁斯的事。因为我记得克拉兹和我对他着迷，
after all the, you know, the, the movies. Is there going to be a sequel, Emily? I hope so. I hope so. I read that. Well, it's 10 years later now. But, I mean, I would sort of want someone to do most of the stunts for me this, this time.
在所有那些，你知道，电影之后。会有续集吗，艾米莉？我希望如此。我希望如此。我读到过。嗯，现在已经是10年之后了。但是，我的意思是，我这次确实希望有人能帮我完成大部分特技。
Do you know that the suit was so heavy that, that a man was my stunt double. I was like, that should tell you something. Good Lord. That you can't find a girl to want to do it. So Emily, when you were telling the story about reading for, what do you call it? Devil, which one is it?
你知道那套套装太重了，以至于一个男人成了我的替身吗？我就想，那应该能说明点什么。天哪。你找不到一个女孩愿意做这件事。所以艾米莉，当你讲那个关于试镜的故事时，你叫它什么？魔鬼，是哪一个？
That's it. You, you slipped into an American accent. They're telling the story very easily. Yeah, you do. You do it so, so well. Is it a hard accent to do? And is there a word that you use that trips you into it?
就是那个。你，你很自然地切换到了美国口音。讲故事讲得很轻松。是的，你确实。你做得太、太好了。这是一种很难学的口音吗？有没有哪个词是你一用就会让你切换过去的？
And then after you say like, you know, Brooklyn or Brit or whatever it is, like, okay, got it, got the stout. No. Is there a trick? Cause everybody's obsessed with Brits who can do an American accent. But do you think they all can do American accents?
然后你说完之后，比如，你知道，布鲁克林或英国人什么的，就像，好吧，明白了，掌握了口音。不。有什么诀窍吗？因为每个人都对能说美国口音的英国人着迷。但你认为他们都能说美国口音吗？
Or are you sometimes like, oh, that's terrible. Much better than Americans can do British accents. Yeah. But do you know, Bridget Jones's diary is on the other day. Oh my God, Renee crushed it. Absolutely. Yeah, she does it very well. The tricky part with the British accent,
还是你有时会觉得，哦，那太糟糕了。比美国人说英国口音好多了。是的。但你知道吗，那天《BJ单身日记》在播。天哪，蕾妮演得太棒了。绝对是。是的，她演得非常好。英国口音的棘手之处在于，
so I hear, I've never tried it, is there's different social classes. And so what we might think is, oh yeah, I'm doing it right now. It's like, no, that's Northern or Southern or Ridge or four. But I guess the same thing with American too, right? There can be Southern, there can be Eastern. For sure.
我听说，我从来没试过，是有不同的社会阶层。所以我们可能认为，哦，是的，我现在说得很对。结果是，不，那是北方或南方或里奇或四。但我猜美国口音也是一样，对吧？可以有南方口音，可以有东方口音。肯定的。
I mean, I think I can be very, very different, my son. They can be very different. But just do the job, yeah? Just do the job. That's not bad, actually. We have discussed this before. Do you remember when you and Justin Thoreau used to do the accent after me?
我的意思是，我认为我可以非常、非常不同，我的儿子。它们可以非常不同。但只要做好工作就行，对吧？只要做好工作。其实那还不赖。我们之前讨论过这个。你还记得你和贾斯汀·塞洛克斯在我之后模仿口音吗？
Yes. And actually yours was better than Justin's. Thank you, really? Much better. Yes. It's recorded now. All right, so is there a word, a little keyword that you used to just...
是的。而且实际上你的比贾斯汀的好。谢谢，真的吗？好多了。是的。现在录下来了。好吧，所以有没有一个词，一个小关键词，你用来……
I wouldn't say a keyword, but there's certain words that are very difficult for English people to say. For example, the name Arthur. Can you say Arthur? Arthur. No, but say it in your accent. Arthur.
我不会说是一个关键词，但有些词对英国人来说非常难说。例如，名字“Arthur”（亚瑟）。你能说“Arthur”吗？Arthur。不，用你的口音说。Arthur。
Arthur. Impossible. Arthur, Arthur, Arthur. That's good, that's good. No, I can never do it. I can never get it. How about this? I find that this one trips up people
Arthur。不可能。Arthur，Arthur，Arthur。那很好，那很好。不，我永远做不到。我永远学不会。这个怎么样？我发现这个词会让来自英国和爱尔兰的人绊倒，
from the UK and Ireland. Arnold Palmer. Arnold Palmer. No, see, Arnold Palmer. Arnold Palmer, Palmer. I can't even say it. The only rule is the R's. That's it.
阿诺德·帕尔默。阿诺德·帕尔默。不，看，阿诺德·帕尔默。阿诺德·帕尔默，帕尔默。我甚至说不出来。唯一的规则就是R音。就是这样。
I think that's why they went to Arnie. It's the R, it's the R, which, do you know why? Because we would say Palmer and that R sound is usually an AR sound for us. Right. Do you know what I mean? Now, Will, did you have to work at all
我想这就是为什么他们叫他阿尼。是R音，是R音，你知道为什么吗？因为我们会说“Palmer”，那个R音对我们来说通常是一个AR音。对吧。你知道我的意思吗？现在，威尔，你有没有为了摆脱你的加拿大口音而努力过？你有没有想过？
to get rid of your Canadian? Did you ever think about it? Oh, fuck. But I thought about it every day, you know? I came and they were like, okay, and we're ready for you to audition. Go ahead. Yeah, my name's Chandler,
哦，该死。但我每天都在想，你知道吗？我来了，他们说，好的，我们准备好让你试镜了。说吧。是的，我叫钱德勒，
and I'm reading, I'm here and friends, and they're like, good, we're nice to meet you. Thank you so much. Fucky, can I expect a callback or what? Wait a minute. I did a little bit. I did have to lose a little bit of the, I noticed.
我正在读，我在这里，朋友们，他们说，好，很高兴见到你。非常感谢。该死，我能期待回电吗，还是怎么着？等一下。我确实做了一点。我确实不得不失去了一点，我注意到了。
Tomorrow? Doing voiceovers about in-house and stuff like that, because as I was reading stuff, I was reading four American products, and so gradually. Like a car company? Well, yeah, eventually car company, of course. But Jason, your mom is British.
明天？做关于内部和类似事情的配音，因为当我阅读材料时，我是在为美国产品阅读，所以逐渐地。像汽车公司？嗯，是的，最终是汽车公司，当然。但是杰森，你妈妈是英国人。
Didn't you pick that up? Your mom's British. I did, yeah, anything I said for a long time, but that was about it, yeah. Anything, and you guys say anything, right? Anything. Anything, anything. I'll say anything.
你没学到吗？你妈妈是英国人。我学到了，是的，我说了很长一段时间的任何事，但仅此而已，是的。任何事，你们说“anything”，对吧？Anything。Anything，anything。我会说“anything”。
My kids sound very American, though. Do they? Yeah, so they're so American. So what's funny is your husband's very American in the best way, and God love him, and we love Krazz, and I wanted to get into, so you guys go into, decide to make this film together, Quiet Place,
不过我的孩子们听起来很美国。是吗？是的，他们太美国了。所以有趣的是，你丈夫以最好的方式非常美国，上帝保佑他，我们爱克拉兹，我想进入，所以你们决定一起拍这部电影，《寂静之地》，
and John directs it to enormous success. Critical box office, you name it. What was that process like when you guys looked at each other and decided, like, yeah, we're gonna do this, and I'm gonna star in it, and you are directing it? Did you guys have, how were those conversations? We're gonna risk the marriage, the harmony, everything.
约翰执导它并取得了巨大的成功。评论、票房，应有尽有。当你们看着对方并决定，是的，我们要拍这个，我要主演，而你执导它时，那个过程是什么样的？你们有，那些对话是怎么进行的？我们要冒着婚姻、和谐、一切的风险。
Exactly, I mean, you sort of feel. Nobody, did it start small? Yeah, I mean, John, I remember John got sent it as like a treatment to be in as an actor, and then he pitched it to me, and he just seemed to have such. Probably unenthusiastically. No, actually really enthusiastically, but just.
正是如此，我的意思是，你会有那种感觉。没有人，它是从小开始的吗？是的，我的意思是，约翰，我记得约翰收到它时是作为一个演员的剧本，然后他把它推销给我，他似乎有如此。可能不太热情。不，实际上非常热情，但只是。
No, I'm kidding. But he had, yeah, it's exactly, because he's so enthusiastic. But it was like a, he had such a vivid world already when he pitched it, that I said, I think you should direct this film, and I pitched a friend of mine to play the part. No way.
不，我开玩笑的。但他有，是的，正是如此，因为他太热情了。但就像，当他推销它时，他已经有了一个如此生动的世界，我说，我认为你应该执导这部电影，我推荐了一个我的朋友来演这个角色。没门。
That I ended up playing, and then I remember we were on a flight, and he had written the whole script, and he wrote it quite quickly, and I read it. Well, there's quite a place, there's no talking, it's two or three pages. No, that's longer, come on, the stage direction. That's so true.
我最终演了那个角色，然后我记得我们在飞机上，他已经写完了整个剧本，他写得很快，我读了它。嗯，那是《寂静之地》，没有对话，有两三页。不，那更长，得了吧，舞台指导。那太真实了。
Great dialogue. And so I read it on a plane, I remember kind of popping my head over the top of the seat, and I said, I know this is terrible, I'm about to completely mess my friend over, but would you ever want me to do it? And he was sort of thrilled. Did he tear up?
伟大的对话。所以我是在飞机上读的，我记得我从座位上方探出头来，我说，我知道这很糟糕，我快要把我朋友的事搞砸了，但你愿意让我演吗？他当时有点激动。他流泪了吗？
Yes, I mean, he did, because he always tears up, he was so ready. I know, it's the best, it's the best, right? They're just primed and ready at all times. Have you ever seen him fake cry? He can squeeze him out, like fake cry, like that. And do you remember that time we were walking? It's astonishing, next time, get him to do it,
是的，我的意思是，他确实流泪了，因为他总是流泪，他准备好了。我知道，这是最好的，这是最好的，对吧？他们总是随时准备着。你见过他假哭吗？他能挤出来，像假哭，像那样。你还记得我们走路的那次吗？太惊人了，下次，让他做一次，
if he ever comes on, it's astonishing. It's like a gift. Like a soap helper actor, right? He just like, flick and switch. Yeah, yeah, it's incredible. Emily, do you remember that time we were walking back from dinner? You, me, and John, we were in New York at my old apartment,
如果他来了，这太惊人了。这就像一种天赋。像个肥皂剧演员，对吧？他就像，一按开关。是的，是的，太不可思议了。艾米莉，你还记得我们从晚餐回来的那次吗？你，我和约翰，我们在纽约我以前的公寓，
and we started talking about something. John started to cry, we both were like, oh my God, John, do you remember that at all? You probably don't. He's always, always crying. I know, we were like, John. I know, just kidding. So what was the conversation like about like, okay,
我们开始谈论某事。约翰开始哭，我们俩都像，天哪，约翰，你还记得吗？你可能不记得了。他总是，总是哭。我知道，我们就像，约翰。我知道，开个玩笑。那么关于，好吧，对话是什么样的，
understand, well, did you guys know how you both are on sets, such that you knew that it was gonna be a good match? Well, that's a great question, because I think we are all quite different people when we're at work, you know, you're just sort of different version of yourself. And I think when you work with new people
明白，嗯，你们知道你们俩在片场是什么样吗，这样你们就知道这会是一个很好的搭配？嗯，那是个好问题，因为我认为我们在工作时都是完全不同的人，你知道，你只是你自己的不同版本。我认为当你和新的人一起工作时，
that are not related to you or that you're not married to, you just have a diplomacy with them that you don't have with your partner. So I knew we were going to have this sort of accelerated version of working together that could either go tits up or not, you know. And like, I think we both found each other quite intense suddenly, you know, at work.
那些与你没有亲属关系或你没有结婚的人，你对他们有一种外交手段，而你对你的伴侣却没有。所以我知道我们将会有这种加速的工作方式，要么搞砸，要么不搞砸，你知道。而且，我想我们都突然觉得对方很紧张，你知道，在工作中。
Like, he was like, God, you're so like, yeah. I was like, you're intense. And he's like, you're focused. And he was directing too, so like, yeah. But I also... So you had to behave a bit, right? Yeah, I had to sort of behave a bit, you know. I don't feel I had to eat shit,
就像，他就像，天哪，你太像，是的。我就像，你很紧张。他说，你很专注。而且他也在执导，所以就像，是的。但我还……所以你得表现得好一点，对吧？是的，我得表现得好一点，你知道。我不觉得我必须吃屎，
but I did sort of uphold, I felt. You were agreeable for a few days. Yeah, we had like one terrible whispered fight on set in a back room in the house. Well, because it was a quiet place, yeah. One whispered argument, which all the crew heard. We're like one of those like, well, I'm trying to tell you what it was about.
但我确实坚持了，我觉得。你表现得很好几天。是的，我们在片场的一个后屋里有过一次可怕的耳语争吵。嗯，因为那是《寂静之地》，是的。一次耳语争吵，所有工作人员都听到了。我们就像那种，嗯，我试着告诉你它是关于什么的。
It was basically about he had this glorious wanna that he wanted to do revealing me sitting at a chair crying about our dead child. For Tracy, that's a one-shot, no coverage. Cameras still roll all the way to the scene. It's a one-shot. No cut. And so with those shots, they're quite technical. So you are often asked to do something again and again.
基本上是因为他有一个辉煌的镜头，他想揭示我坐在椅子上为我们死去的孩子哭泣。对于特蕾西来说，那是一个镜头，没有覆盖。摄像机一直滚动到场景结束。这是一个镜头。没有剪辑。所以对于那些镜头，它们非常技术性。所以你经常被要求一遍又一遍地做某事。
And I was concerned that I wouldn't be able to... If he started with that wide wanna, that I wouldn't be able to... Because I'm not someone who can cry on demand all the time. And I have to go to a rather ugly place. So I'd say, can you start with the closer coverage of this emotional stuff? Right.
我很担心我无法……如果他从那个宽镜头开始，我就无法……因为我不是那种能随时随地哭出来的人。我必须去一个相当丑陋的地方。所以我说，你能从这些情感戏的近景开始吗？对。
And I think he just, because of light and everything, as you know, Jason, when you're directing, you have a million other things telling you you have to do it differently. You don't wanna accommodate some goddamn actor. You wanna accommodate your wife. And they're actory notes. So I do remember just pulling him in the back room
我想他只是，因为光线和一切，正如你所知，杰森，当你执导时，你有无数其他事情告诉你必须以不同的方式做。你不想迁就某个该死的演员。你想迁就你的妻子。而且那是演员的笔记。所以我确实记得把他拉进后屋，
and being like, you told me that you would start with a one-shot play. No. Well, how did it settle? We just drank a lot of whiskey when we got home. And it was great. We had these long car rides on the way to work and back. And like, because I also...
并说，你告诉我你会从一个镜头开始。不。嗯，它是怎么解决的？我们回家时喝了很多威士忌。这很棒。我们在上班和下班的路上有很长的车程。而且，因为我也……
So he just had a bottle between his legs, driving you home. Exactly. Just a bottle. Why does it have to be between his legs? It's something I would... Bottles are usually too big for the cup holder. True.
所以他只是在两腿之间放了一瓶酒，开车送你回家。正是。只是一瓶。为什么非得在两腿之间？这是我会……瓶子通常对杯架来说太大了。真的。
But you know, I will say, I mean, I think there was a part of me starting the film that felt that I was bracing for impact a little bit, like will-off marriage and divorce, you know? But I just respect him so much. I think he's so talented. I wasn't aware of how talented at directing he was. I don't think he knew.
但我会说，我的意思是，我想我在开始这部电影时，有一部分觉得自己有点在为冲击做准备，就像婚姻和离婚，你知道？但我非常尊重他。我认为他很有才华。我不知道他执导的才华有多高。我不认为他知道。
And I remember when we were going into it, I remember going, do you know how to shoot this film? Like, are you sure you know what you're doing? Oh, great. And he turned out to be so visual. Yeah, just incredible. And I was stunned. Yeah, yeah.
我记得当我们进入它时，我记得我说，你知道怎么拍这部电影吗？就像，你确定你知道你在做什么吗？哦，太棒了。结果他非常有视觉感。是的，简直不可思议。我惊呆了。是的，是的。
It was incredible. It was amazing. Well, you know, Emily, I always say you have to fall in respect, not fall in love. Wow, man. Oh, you're welcome. Do you say that? I like that.
太不可思议了。太棒了。嗯，你知道，艾米莉，我总是说你必须坠入尊重，而不是坠入爱河。哇，伙计。哦，不客气。你这么说吗？我喜欢这个。
You really do. You're welcome. It's on the smaller back, I think, isn't it? You've been saying that since the day you read that off the bathroom wall, hey, I was in John's first film. Yes. Interviews with hideous men for 30 seconds. He is such a talented guy, as we know.
你真的这么做。不客气。我想是在小背上，不是吗？你从在浴室墙上读到那句话的那天起就一直这么说，嘿，我演了约翰的第一部电影。是的。采访丑陋的男人30秒。他是一个非常有才华的人，正如我们所知。
And he is, and I joke about his enthusiasm, his enthusiasm is beyond infectious. We should have him on the show. I know, hang on, let's stop talking, but I will say. I'd love for you to just pan your camera over, Emily, and he's just sitting right next to you. I just set off camera since he's been staring at the camera. See, you think this riddled with loathing for all of you.
而且他是，我开玩笑说他的热情，他的热情简直是极具感染力。我们应该请他上节目。我知道，等等，别说了，但我会说。我真希望你能把摄像机转过去，艾米莉，他就坐在你旁边。我只是在摄像机外，因为他一直盯着摄像机。看，你认为这充满了对你们所有人的厌恶。
I had one other question about that, because when you're making a quiet place in the sequel with your husband, when you're acting, you go into that place in your brain where you're focused on your work, is that what happened when you were shooting scenes where you would completely be in the scene and in your head as the character
我还有一个关于那个的问题，因为当你和你的丈夫制作《寂静之地》续集时，当你表演时，你进入大脑中那个专注于工作的空间，当你拍摄场景时，你会完全进入场景并在脑海中作为角色，
and forget almost that your husband was directing? You know what I mean? Did you see him as a... Did you switch off and on in your brain and see him as a director and then cut that husband? Yeah, I honestly saw him as my husband again once we were in the car driving home. It's like we got our secret language back,
几乎忘记了你的丈夫在执导？你知道我的意思吗？你把他看作一个……你在大脑中切换开关，把他看作导演，然后切断丈夫的身份？是的，我老实说，一旦我们在开车回家的路上，我就又把他看作我的丈夫了。就像我们找回了我们的秘密语言，
whereas on set there's something a little more sort of performative about everything, you know? But I do feel he is somebody in a professional sense who sees all of me and all of what I do and likes it. So he's very freeing and he's an actor, so he knows to give you space and he knows not to come in. Sean, you go through, you were saying that you wish, Scotty, you see him sometimes as your husband
而在片场，一切都有点表演性，你知道吗？但我确实觉得他在专业意义上是一个能看到我的一切以及我所做的一切并喜欢它的人。所以他非常自由，而且他是一名演员，所以他知道给你空间，他知道不要介入。肖恩，你经历过，你说你希望，斯科蒂，你有时把他看作你的丈夫，
and not just as a sloppy Joe delivery service, you know what I mean? They love the role play. But I love him at both. He goes outside, he hits a doorbell. Sean makes him wait and I'm like, oh, thank you for the delivery, sir. Boys, that's sloppy, look at that, let me clean this up.
而不是仅仅作为一个邋遢的乔送货服务，你知道我的意思吗？他们喜欢角色扮演。但我喜欢他的两面。他走到外面，按门铃。肖恩让他等，我就像，哦，谢谢你的送货，先生。伙计们，那太邋遢了，看看那个，让我清理一下。
You know, there's two in here, would you like to join me? Do you think John would be as good an actor for you if you were directing him? What a brilliant question. I think I would be so scared to direct him. I would not want to. Just because he would just be pushing back like, what, really, you want me to what?
你知道，这里有两个，你想加入我吗？你认为如果由你执导，约翰会是一个好演员吗？多么精彩的问题。我想我会非常害怕执导他。我不想。仅仅因为他会反驳说，什么，真的，你想让我做什么？
Well, I think because he would, I feel deep down, he would visually have a much better idea for how it should be done. I think he would listen to me very much from an acting perspective because I would give him a couple of notes when we were shooting. Sure, but he would second guess you
嗯，我想因为他会，我内心深处觉得，他在视觉上会有更好的想法，知道应该怎么做。我想他会非常从表演的角度听我的，因为我们在拍摄时我会给他一些笔记。当然，但他会质疑你
on your coverage strategy and blocking. Of course, I feel like I would be completely, completely second guessed at every turn, yeah. So you do that film with John, incredible success. You had also done, I think before, worked with our other good friend, Justin Thoreau, whom we mentioned before. Old sleeves together.
关于你的覆盖策略和调度。当然，我觉得我会在每一个转折点都被完全、完全质疑，是的。所以你和约翰拍了那部电影，取得了不可思议的成功。你之前也做过，我想，和我们的另一个好朋友贾斯汀·塞洛克斯合作过，我们之前提到过。老袖子在一起。
Inferior accent to mine, in virtually every accent. Yeah, it's way worse. But what he lacks in sort of accent ability, he makes up for in sleevelessness. Do you, when you did Girl on the Train, you talk about not being able to access, I felt like that was such a deeply emotional performance that you gave that was very, very small, that was very,
几乎在每种口音上都比我的口音差。是的，差远了。但他缺乏口音能力，他在无袖方面弥补了。当你拍《火车上的女孩》时，你谈到无法进入，我觉得你给出的那是一个非常深刻的情感表演，非常、非常小，非常、
and of course, there was all this stuff behind it that you find out that sort of, as we peel back, we find out about this character. Was that a difficult, because you said you had to go to an ugly place, I imagine you probably had to live in quite an ugly place. And I know you don't want to maybe talk about your process. I'm not asking that.
当然，背后有所有这些东西，你发现，当我们剥开时，我们发现了这个角色。那是一个困难的，因为你说你必须去一个丑陋的地方，我想你可能必须生活在一个相当丑陋的地方。我知道你可能不想谈论你的过程。我不是在问那个。
Well, it's also just, I don't know how interesting it is because I don't know if my process is sort of specific enough to make an interesting point about. Yeah, but so forget your actual process. Was it a difficult, was it a difficult process of making that film because it was so? That was a very difficult shoot. That was a very difficult one.
嗯，这也只是，我不知道它有多有趣，因为我不知道我的过程是否足够具体，能提出一个有趣的观点。是的，但忘了你实际的过程。制作那部电影是一个困难的过程吗，因为它太？那是一次非常困难的拍摄。那是一次非常困难的。
And some of them, even if you're doing something dark, like I remember on Sicario, we're doing something really dark and really intense. God damn it, I love that one. I love Sicario. But the experience was sort of wonderful. I think there was something about just the depth of despair that that character in Girl on the Train goes to
有些，即使你在做一些黑暗的事情，就像我记得在《边境杀手》中，我们在做一些非常黑暗和非常激烈的事情。该死，我喜欢那部。我喜欢《边境杀手》。但那种经历是相当美妙的。我想是因为《火车上的女孩》中那个角色所达到的绝望深度，
and dealing with addiction and everything, and me having to, not having dealt with addiction, I had to dive quite deep into a world that seemed inaccessible to me in the beginning. So it was a long process to figure out how to play her and quite an arduous one. And the shoot was hard and I was pregnant and I couldn't tell anyone.
以及处理成瘾和一切，而我不得不，没有处理过成瘾，我不得不深入到一个起初对我来说似乎无法进入的世界。所以这是一个漫长的过程，去弄清楚如何扮演她，而且相当艰苦。拍摄很艰难，我怀孕了，我不能告诉任何人。
And so I just felt exhausted and sick all the time. So I just remember that being a hard shoot, mainly because of Justin's fashion sense, but he has got incredible arms. And we will be right back. This episode of SmartLess is brought to you in part by Diet Coke. From its inception 40 years ago, Diet Coke has been loved for its crisp, refreshing taste.
所以我一直感到筋疲力尽和恶心。所以我只记得那是一次艰难的拍摄，主要是因为贾斯汀的时尚品味，但他有不可思议的手臂。我们马上回来。本期SmartLess由健怡可乐部分赞助。从40年前诞生以来，健怡可乐就因其清脆、清爽的口感而受到喜爱。
Just a delicious pick me up. And if you're caught in the holiday season mayhem, let Diet Coke remind you to love what you love. I do like the holidays. I also really like Diet Coke. And I find that Diet Coke kind of gets me through those moments because it's a nice little pick me up. If I'm at a party, I'm having people over,
只是一种美味的提神饮料。如果你陷入了节日季的混乱中，让健怡可乐提醒你爱所爱。我确实喜欢节日。我也真的很喜欢健怡可乐。我发现健怡可乐能帮我度过那些时刻，因为它是一种很好的小提神饮料。如果我在聚会上，我有客人，
I'm watching the game or whatever. I just feel like it's always one of those moments of like, hey, can I get you something? And I'm like, yeah, can I get a Diet Coke? It feels so good saying that. If I'm at a party or at a restaurant or even if I'm just at home, I guess I don't ask anybody. When I'm at home, I guess I just ask myself for one.
我在看比赛什么的。我只是觉得这总是那种时刻，比如，嘿，我能给你拿点什么吗？我就像，是的，我能来一罐健怡可乐吗？说这话感觉太好了。如果我在聚会上或餐馆里，或者即使我只是在家里，我想我不问任何人。当我在家时，我想我只是问自己要一罐。
I'm kind of like internally going, can I get a Diet Coke? And the answer is always yes. This year, Diet Coke is celebrating people who enjoy life without worrying too much about what those around them think. Diet Coke is the fuel to unapologetically just live your life and love what you love.
我内心有点像，我能来一罐健怡可乐吗？答案总是肯定的。今年，健怡可乐正在庆祝那些享受生活而不必太担心周围人想法的人。健怡可乐是让你毫无歉意地过自己的生活并爱所爱的燃料。
I love that Diet Coke is in its 40th year because I think that your 40s are when your confidence peaks and you become the best version of yourself. There's a freedom that comes with abandoning the shoulds in life and just loving what you love. And just know, if you're having a Diet Coke
我喜欢健怡可乐进入第40个年头，因为我认为你的40岁是你自信心达到顶峰的时候，你成为最好的自己。放弃生活中的“应该”并只爱所爱会带来一种自由。只要知道，如果你正在喝健怡可乐，
wherever you are, I probably am too. So join us in grabbing a Diet Coke this holiday season, doing what you love the most, whatever it is. Love what you love. SmartLess is brought to you in part by Solo Stove. I'm a backyard person. I like being in my backyard, spending time in it, especially here in California,
无论你在哪里，我可能也在喝。所以加入我们，在这个节日季拿一罐健怡可乐，做你最喜欢的事，无论它是什么。爱所爱。SmartLess由Solo Stove部分赞助。我是一个后院的人。我喜欢在我的后院，花时间在里面，特别是在加州这里，
but also when I'm on the East Coast in the other part of the year. And there's just, I don't know, there's nothing quite like the feeling of gathering around a warm fire on a cool evening. And I can tell you that a smokeless fire pit from Solo Stove makes your outdoor moments even more memorable,
但也包括我在一年中的另一部分时间在东海岸时。而且只是，我不知道，没有什么比在凉爽的夜晚围坐在温暖的火堆旁的感觉更好了。我可以告诉你，来自Solo Stove的无烟火坑让你的户外时刻更加难忘，
because instead of having to constantly dodge campfire fumes, you can just sit back and relax and actually enjoy the fire without constantly going white rabbits, white rabbits, white rabbits. Did you guys ever do that? We used to say white rabbits when the smoke would get in our eyes.
因为你不必不断地躲避篝火烟雾，你可以坐下来放松，真正享受火，而不必不断地念叨“白兔，白兔，白兔”。你们做过那个吗？当烟雾进入我们的眼睛时，我们过去常说“白兔”。
Anyway, you don't have to do that with a Solo Stove. And during Solo Stove's holiday event sale, you can get a great deal on a Solo Stove fire pit. I can't wait this holiday to be, and I am gonna be on the East Coast, who I like doing the fire pit when it's really cold outside. Because I think that's kind of fun,
无论如何，你不需要用Solo Stove做那个。在Solo Stove的节日活动促销期间，你可以以优惠的价格买到Solo Stove火坑。我等不及这个节日了，我会在东海岸，我喜欢在外面很冷的时候用火坑。因为我觉得那很有趣，
makes it kind of cozy, kind of interesting. Especially like if you get a little bit of snow on the ground. Guys, then it's magical holidays, come on. Solo Stove fire pits are brilliantly engineered to be easy to use and they're built to last. Easy to light with a few bits of starter, your fire is blazing in minutes.
让它变得舒适，有点意思。特别是如果地上有一点雪。伙计们，那真是神奇的节日，得了吧。Solo Stove火坑经过精心设计，易于使用，而且经久耐用。用一点引火物很容易点燃，你的火几分钟内就会燃烧起来。
They're so confident that you'll love it. They offer a lifetime warranty and a 30-day free return policy. I mean, talk about confidence. Let the gifting begin. Shop Solo Stove's holiday event sale for huge site-wide savings, and get $10 off with promo code SMARTLESS,
他们非常有信心你会喜欢它。他们提供终身保修和30天免费退货政策。我的意思是，谈谈信心。让送礼开始吧。选购Solo Stove的节日活动促销，享受巨大的全站折扣，并使用促销代码SMARTLESS获得10美元优惠，
plus a lifetime warranty and free 30-day returns. Get an extra $10 off holiday deals at solastove.com, promo code SMARTLESS. MUSIC SmartLess is supported by FedEx. This holiday season, be ready for what's next with Picture Proof of Delivery from FedEx. Picture Proof of Delivery provides photo confirmation
加上终身保修和免费30天退货。在solastove.com获取额外10美元的节日优惠，促销代码SMARTLESS。音乐SmartLess由FedEx支持。这个节日季，用FedEx的送达图片证明为接下来做好准备。送达图片证明提供照片确认
of your delivered package, so both consumers and businesses can have greater peace of mind. FedEx Express and FedEx Ground are the first nationwide carriers to provide Picture Proof of Delivery without requiring an account or login for residential deliveries. And it's available for free on the FedEx website and app. And the best part is you don't have to enroll in any program. It's the holidays.
你的已送达包裹，这样消费者和企业都能有更大的安心。FedEx Express和FedEx Ground是第一批提供送达图片证明的全国性承运商，无需住宅送达的账户或登录。它在FedEx网站和应用程序上免费提供。最棒的部分是你不需要注册任何程序。这是节日。
We're all trying to get things everywhere. And we're trying to send gifts to people that are on this side of the country and that side of the country and they're overseas and they're overseas and they're over mountains and rivers and blah, blah, blah, blah. And we need to know that our packages are getting there this time of year. And FedEx, who are when it comes to all of these sort of express carriers, they are my personal fave. This is an actual endorsement.
我们都在努力把东西送到各地。我们正在努力给在这个国家这一边和那一边的人送礼物，他们在大洋彼岸，他们在大洋彼岸，他们在山川之上，等等等等。我们需要知道我们的包裹在这个时候送到了。而FedEx，当谈到所有这些快递承运商时，他们是我个人的最爱。这是一个实际的代言。
I love FedEx. I can't live without them. And now they do the picture perfect thing. Yeah, it's amazing. I'm so stoked and knowing that my stuff is getting there and knowing that my stuff is for the people who are sending it to us because we got kids. We got all these kids and we got presents and stuff and blah, blah, blah, blah.
我爱FedEx。没有他们我活不下去。现在他们做了图片证明的事情。是的，太棒了。我非常激动，知道我的东西送到了，知道我的东西是给那些寄给我们的人的，因为我们有孩子。我们有所有这些孩子，我们有礼物什么的，等等等等。
It's kind of like one of those things like once again, FedEx. You done good. All right. So ship with FedEx and be ready for this holiday season with picture proof of delivery. Great idea. FedEx, be ready for what's next. And now back to the show.
这就像那种事情，再一次，FedEx。你做得很好。好吧。所以用FedEx发货，并用送达图片证明为这个节日季做好准备。好主意。FedEx，为接下来做好准备。现在回到节目。
How about that mothering thing? I mean, you're constantly working. It's so great and your kids are fantastic. And your marriage is fantastic. It seems so difficult to keep it all healthy and harmonious. And there's probably no secret to that either, right? Well, I just don't know if I ever get it right. I don't know if the juggle is ever sufficient on either side.
那个母亲的事情怎么样？我的意思是，你一直在工作。这太棒了，你的孩子很棒。你的婚姻很棒。保持这一切健康和谐似乎很难。而且可能也没有什么秘密，对吧？嗯，我只是不知道我是否做对了。我不知道这种平衡在任何一方是否足够。
I guess none of us will know until the kids are 25. But it is interesting. Like I think as a mother, you do, and if you are working as well, I think women get asked a lot more, like how do you juggle it? And I don't know if men or dads get asked that as much. It's weird. It is like that sort of tradition where like, well, it's just a film. The guy's going to be away at work all day while the mom is taking care of it.
我想直到孩子们25岁之前，我们谁也不会知道。但这很有趣。就像我认为作为一个母亲，你确实，如果你也在工作，我认为女性被问得更多，比如你是怎么平衡的？我不知道男人或爸爸是否被问得那么多。这很奇怪。这就像那种传统，比如，嗯，这只是一部电影。男人整天在外工作，而妈妈在照顾它。
Like it is so antiquated. Like I don't think John's ever been asked that question, you know? And I was just, and I was doing a film in Atlanta this summer. And I was sort of amazed how many people said to me, where are your kids? Right. And I just want to be like, where are you all kids? I know, I know. You know what I mean?
就像它太陈旧了。我不认为约翰被问过那个问题，你知道？我当时，我今年夏天在亚特兰大拍一部电影。我很惊讶有多少人对我说，你的孩子在哪里？对。我只想说，你们的孩子都在哪里？我知道，我知道。你知道我的意思吗？
Like it's so strange. Isn't that the worst thing? Yeah, like you should be with them 24. Yeah, and people ask, Jason, have you gotten that before too? And I see people sometimes, also sometimes people that you know, and they'll do this thing with this sort of like fake inquisitive because they really want to know what your, what the deal is, like what they go. So their way they do it is they dress it up with, where are you?
就像这太奇怪了。那不是最糟糕的事情吗？是的，就像你应该24小时和他们在一起。是的，人们问，杰森，你以前也遇到过吗？我有时看到人们，有时也是你认识的人，他们会做这种事，带着那种假装好奇，因为他们真的想知道你的，交易是什么，比如他们去。所以他们这样做的方式是他们用“你在哪里？”来包装它。
Yeah, and it's with that sort of smile. Just so they, you mean, well, just so they could dig a little bit and find out what's going on. Yeah, they do it. People do it all the time. Well, because they want to know, by the way, so even if you're a working mom, they want to be, there's a little bit of shame in there. Like, so you're off doing this. You're making your movie.
是的，带着那种微笑。只是为了，你的意思，好吧，只是为了他们可以挖掘一点，找出发生了什么。是的，他们做到了。人们一直这样做。嗯，因为他们想知道，顺便说一下，所以即使你是一个职业母亲，他们也想，里面有一点羞耻感。比如，所以你出去做这个。你在拍你的电影。
Who's looking after your kids? I'm concerned about your kids. It's like, fuck off. I got it from here. Yes, yes, it truly, it's exactly right. Yeah, and it's that sort of faux care, you know, and you're like, no, you're kind of judging me because I think maybe our job is perceived as being quite fun and sort of frivolous.
谁在照顾你的孩子？我担心你的孩子。就像，滚开。我能搞定。是的，是的，它确实，完全正确。是的，那是那种虚假的关心，你知道，你就像，不，你有点在评判我，因为我想也许我们的工作被认为是非常有趣和轻浮的。
Right, right. Exactly, right. That you're choosing having a whale of a time over being with your kids, you know. Exactly, right. Yeah, yeah. Exactly, and also for me, I find like the added layer because, you know, I have kids with my ex-wife and then I'm divorced. Yes.
对，对。完全正确。你选择享受美好时光而不是和你的孩子在一起，你知道。完全正确。是的，是的。完全正确，而且对我来说，我发现就像额外的层面，因为，你知道，我和我的前妻有孩子，然后我离婚了。是的。
And they have an added layer of like, what's the deal? Like, how involved are you? Yeah, how involved are you? What do you mean, how fucking involved? They're my fucking kids. And like, also like, oh, let me break down for you how it goes and what nights and who stays where. Are you out of your fucking mind? And why do they care?
他们有一个额外的层面，比如，交易是什么？比如，你参与了多少？是的，你参与了多少？你什么意思，他妈的参与了多少？他们是我他妈的孩子。而且就像，哦，让我为你分解它是怎么进行的，哪些晚上，谁待在哪里。你他妈的疯了吗？他们为什么要在意？
Why do they care? You know why usually it's a projection? Yeah. Because they're deeply, if you're happy, if you're happy in your own situation, you wouldn't have the time to, you wouldn't care to ask. That's right, exactly. There you go. I have to say, John and I talked about it all the time.
他们为什么要在意？你知道为什么通常这是一种投射吗？是的。因为他们内心深处，如果你自己过得幸福，如果你在自己的生活中感到幸福，你就不会有时间，也不会在意去过问。没错，就是这样。你说对了。我必须说，我和约翰一直都在谈论这件事。
You are the most beautiful dad. We talk about it so much. It's really stunning. I love watching you. Yeah, the best. Oh, thank you. He's talking about adopting me. Oh, gosh.
你是最棒的爸爸。我们经常谈论这个。这真的很令人惊叹。我喜欢看你（带孩子）。是的，你是最棒的。哦，谢谢。他正在跟我谈领养我的事。哦，天哪。
What is, Emily, what is the thing you like to do when you and or John aren't working? What is the thing you like to do with your kids the most? I mean, I really love baking with them. We love baking like some stuff. Really? Yeah, I just love it. Me too, I just got into it. And I love taking them out to parks.
艾米丽，当你和约翰不工作的时候，你最喜欢做什么？你最喜欢和孩子们一起做什么？我是说，我真的很喜欢和他们一起烘焙。我们喜欢烘焙一些东西。真的吗？是的，我就是很喜欢。我也是，我刚开始接触。而且我喜欢带他们去公园。
I love a park. I love a swing. I love all of it. Yeah. Now, are you the kind of park goer that brings one of those big sheets and puts it down all over the grass and just sits down cross-legged? No. No, I feel like I'm usually ill-prepared with the sheet, you know, with the picnic blanket.
我喜欢公园。我喜欢荡秋千。我喜欢这一切。是的。那么，你是那种会带上一张大毯子，铺在草地上，然后盘腿坐下的那种公园常客吗？不。不，我觉得我通常没准备好毯子，你知道，就是野餐垫。
Yeah, I just, when's the last time you guys set crisscross applesauce? Like, you can't do that anymore after like 12. You just, the hips don't work. Do you want to hear the saddest story? This is a very sad story and it's to the point of crisscross applesauce. So, we had this incredible dancer in Mary Poppins who was the lead guy in this massive dance number. This guy is a lethal machine dance king.
是啊，你们上次盘腿坐是什么时候？大概12岁以后就做不到了。你的髋关节受不了。你想听个最悲惨的故事吗？这是一个非常悲伤的故事，而且和盘腿坐有关。我们在《欢乐满人间》里有一位非常出色的舞者，他是那场大型舞蹈表演的领舞。这家伙简直就是一台致命的舞蹈机器。
Yeah. He was incredible. He was in the park on the weekend. He was sitting crisscross applesauce. He saw a friend jumped up, snapped both his ankles because his legs went to sleep. No way. Done. Was cut from the film.
是的。他太棒了。周末他在公园里。他当时正盘腿坐着。他看到一个朋友，跳了起来，结果双脚踝都断了，因为他的腿麻了。不会吧。完了。被电影剪掉了。
Wait, because his legs fell asleep? His legs fell asleep. This is a very flexible man. This is a guy who can do a box split and he shouldn't have been sitting with his legs crossed. Snap, snap, instantly. Isn't that awful? I've just always seen that sort of, that tableau of people sitting on a blanket and a park
等等，因为他的腿麻了？他的腿麻了。这是一个身体非常灵活的人。这是一个能做横叉的人，他不该盘腿坐的。咔嚓，咔嚓，瞬间就断了。这不是很可怕吗？我一直看到那种人们坐在公园毯子上的画面，
and I just, there's no way anybody there is comfortable. Right. There's nobody. No. And there's fucking bugs crawling around on your food and I don't get it. I like to, sometimes I like to go to the park on a weekend and we meet my lady and we sit on a blanket. Oh God, I don't like the way you said that.
我总觉得，坐在那儿的人根本不舒服。没错。根本没人舒服。而且还有该死的虫子在你的食物上爬来爬去，我不明白。我喜欢，有时我喜欢在周末去公园，我和我太太见面，我们坐在毯子上。哦天哪，我不喜欢你刚才那种说法。
Yeah. We smoke a little grass. We smoke a little grass and people kind of wander by and we talk to people. You should try that in your Canadian accent. It would be even sexier. Fuck, we're smoking weed out here. It is the last thing anybody in Los Angeles ever does and I get that people in New York do it a lot because there's not, no one's got a front yard, back yard, anything because
是啊。我们抽点草。我们抽点草，人们走来走去，我们和他们聊天。你应该用你的加拿大口音试试。那会更性感。该死，我们在外面抽大麻。这是洛杉矶人最不会做的事，我明白纽约人经常这么做，因为那里没有前院、后院，什么都没有，因为
it's so small, right? It's true. Emily, go, I want to go back to when you, Nutscape, we want to talk more about the grass. I didn't want to do a little more park blanket time. Oh God. I wanted to ask you because I do think it's, I'm kind of stuck on this thing. I think it's fascinating how you explained, how you entered the business by just kind of almost, I don't want to put words in your mouth, but almost like a hobby.
地方太小了，对吧？确实。艾米丽，回来，我想回到你……Nutscape，我们想多聊聊草的事。我不想再多聊公园毯子的事了。哦天哪。我想问你，因为我确实觉得，我有点纠结于这件事。我觉得你解释自己进入这个行业的方式非常迷人，几乎就像是一种爱好。我不想替你代言，但几乎就像是玩票。
You're like, yeah, I did a point. Sure. I'll pursue it. It's fine. Oh my God. I see a difference. It's back. Which is part of the reason.
你说，是的，我试了一下。当然。我会追求它。没关系。哦天哪。我看到了区别。它回来了。这也是原因之一。
So as you now have become more successful and worked a lot more and shown that you are this huge talent. I'll put your hand down. I can't look at the pinky splint anymore. I'll put it down. Show that you're this big talent in the business. Have you gained a little more hunger for pursuing it or are you still kind of in that same space? What he wants to know is how much money do you make?
所以，随着你现在变得越来越成功，工作越来越多，并证明了你是一个巨大的天才。把你的手放下。我再也看不下那个小指夹板了。我会放下的。证明了你是业内的大天才。你对追求事业的渴望是否增加了一点，还是你仍然处于那种状态？他想知道的是你赚了多少钱？
No. Just say it for fun. That is enough enough. No, you want to know my ardent passion for it, which I absolutely have fallen madly in love with it. It was a slow burn. Okay, good. Because I was going to say, if it did go away, how would you feel now that I hope it
不。只是随口问问。够了够了。不，你是想知道我对此的热情，我绝对已经疯狂地爱上了它。这是一个缓慢的过程。好吧，很好。因为我本来想说，如果它消失了，你现在会感觉如何，我希望它
never goes away? Destroyed. Okay. Good. I was just curious because it was... It would be girl on the train. Girl on the train. Girl on the train.
永远不会消失？会崩溃的。好吧。很好。我只是好奇，因为它是……那会是《火车上的女孩》。《火车上的女孩》。《火车上的女孩》。
Okay, good. No, I would truly be desperately sad because I love it deeply. I deeply, deeply love it. Not going to happen. It was a slow burn, falling in love with it. So you developed the love as it went on. Yeah, for sure. Oh, God.
好吧，很好。不，我真的会感到绝望和悲伤，因为我深深地爱着它。我深深地、深深地爱着它。不会发生的。这是一个缓慢的过程，慢慢爱上它。所以你是随着时间的推移培养出了这种爱。是的，当然。哦，天哪。
I understand that. Of course. Now, do you see, pardon me if I have not heard or seen of your recent Broadway successes, but do you see yourself maybe doing a play like Sean here on Broadway said? I would love to. I would really love to. Sean, are you going to be singing in your... Nope, not this one.
我理解。当然。现在，你是否，请原谅我如果我没有听说或看过你最近在百老汇的成功，但你是否考虑过像肖恩在这里说的那样去百老汇演戏？我很想。我真的非常想。肖恩，你要在你的……里唱歌吗？不，不是这一部。
No, God, no. Okay. Never again. That I would not want to do, but I would love to do a play. I started out doing plays, and I haven't done one for forever, and I would really love, I would love to. But you do sing and dance, right? Yeah, but I wouldn't want to do it every night, like eight shows a week, who wants to do that?
不，天哪，不。好吧。再也不了。那是我不想做的，但我很想演一部戏。我刚开始就是演戏的，我已经很久没演了，我真的很想，我很想。但你会唱歌跳舞，对吧？是的，但我不想每天晚上都做，比如一周八场演出，谁想做那个？
One of my brothers, who I loved dearly, was like, what are you complaining about? You just have to work three hours a night. I'm like... It's not what... You have no idea. Did you throw your dim sum at him? Some of my dim sum. No, it's like an... I mean, people can joke all they want, but it's like being an athlete.
我的一位兄弟，我非常爱他，他说，你在抱怨什么？你只需要每晚工作三个小时。我说……那不是……你根本不知道。你有没有把点心扔向他？扔了一点点心。不，这就像一个……我是说，人们可以随便开玩笑，但这就像当运动员一样。
You have to wake up, eat the right food, make sure you sleep, exercise, workout, stretch before you do it. It's like a whole thing from the second you wake up to the second you go to bed. It's just a... Yes, yes. What do you find the hardest part? Is it eat the right food? Yeah, probably, because I reward myself at the end of the night.
你必须起床，吃正确的食物，确保睡眠，锻炼，在表演前拉伸。从你醒来的那一刻到你上床睡觉的那一刻，这都是一整套流程。这只是一个……是的，是的。你觉得最难的部分是什么？是吃正确的食物吗？是的，可能吧，因为我在晚上结束时会奖励自己。
The sloppy joes. I ate like shit yesterday. My God, Sean, you would have been so proud of me. What did you eat? I didn't have any dinner and I just was like, fuck it, I was just by myself and I just ate ice cream. I ate a bowl of ice cream. Yeah, why would you?
邋遢乔三明治。我昨天吃得像垃圾一样。天哪，肖恩，你会为我感到骄傲的。你吃了什么？我没吃晚饭，我当时就想，去他的，我一个人，我就吃了冰淇淋。我吃了一碗冰淇淋。是啊，你为什么要那样？
Good for you. I thought you were going to say something really boring, like broth, and I was like, oh, come on. No, no, no, no. No, I had a... Last night I was... Did you take it to bed with you? Did you wake up with a bowl next to you in the morning?
为你感到高兴。我以为你会说一些很无聊的东西，比如肉汤，我当时想，哦，算了吧。不，不，不，不。不，我有一个……昨晚我……你把它带到床上去了吗？你早上醒来时碗还在旁边吗？
Like a bad after-school special? Little Willie's got a problem? I did think of Jason. This is how fucked up how much he has fucking polluted. Yeah. As I was eating it, I was like, oh, fuck it. If Bateman saw this, he would be saying this and he would be saying that. And I'd be like, hey, daddy.
就像那种糟糕的课后特别节目？小威利有麻烦了？我确实想到了杰森。这就是他该死地污染了多少。是的。当我吃的时候，我想，哦，去他的。如果贝特曼看到这个，他会这么说，他会那么说。我会说，嘿，爸爸。
You'd be 750 fucking pounds if I wasn't in your life. And me the same. I think about you all the time too, right? When I'm about to have something real salty. You eat well. Emily, you eat well. You like to eat well? Or you're like, I wish I was eating like shit.
如果我不在你生活中，你会重达750磅。我也是。我也一直想着你，对吧？当我准备吃点很咸的东西时。你吃得很好。艾米丽，你吃得很好。你喜欢吃得好吗？还是你觉得，我真希望我能吃得像垃圾一样。
Like gross. No, I have like bouts of eating really well and then bouts of eating badly. It's sort of like full. Well, the baking though. I mean, that can get away from you. You got to watch out for that. That can get starchy quick. Sean just taught himself how to make a cheesecake two weeks ago.
比如恶心的东西。不，我有时会吃得很好，有时会吃得很差。这就像是……嗯，烘焙的事。我是说，那可能会失控。你得小心点。那可能会很快变得淀粉含量很高。肖恩两周前刚自学了怎么做芝士蛋糕。
Oh, I'd love to learn how to make a cheesecake. Oh my God. He had a spare Wednesday. Have we talked about it yet on the show? No. We sure haven't. Sean, on Sunday night, we were at our friends for dinner and he goes, and they're like, Sean made dessert and they brought out this fucking cheesecake that he had made.
哦，我很想学怎么做芝士蛋糕。哦天哪。他有一个空闲的周三。我们在节目里谈过这个吗？没有。我们确实还没谈过。肖恩，周日晚上，我们在朋友家吃晚饭，他说，他们说，肖恩做了甜点，然后他们端出了这个他做的该死的芝士蛋糕。
Sean. With an unbelievable graham cracker, cruster, whatever you want to do. He's trying to figure out how to fill a week. Yeah. So he decided to teach himself how to make a cheesecake. It was so good. Sean, was it like a classic cheesecake or was it like a cheesecake? It takes about nine hours to make it because you know what a water bath is.
肖恩。配上令人难以置信的全麦饼干底，或者任何你想做的。他正试图弄清楚如何填满一周的时间。是的。所以他决定自学如何做芝士蛋糕。太好吃了。肖恩，那是经典的芝士蛋糕还是那种……？做它需要大约九个小时，因为你知道什么是水浴法吗？
I'm sorry, a water bath. Yeah. A water bath, yeah. A water bath. Yeah, so you had to make the water bath and put the tin foil in the springform pan. Oh, God. And then you have to make the top of the sour cream layer. That's a lot of work.
抱歉，水浴法。是的。水浴法，是的。水浴法。是的，所以你必须做水浴，把锡纸放在活底模具里。哦，天哪。然后你还得做顶部的酸奶油层。那工作量很大。
It was delicious. Did you do a double bake? It was really nice. It was really nice. Yes. Well, you put it in the oven for an hour and you let it cook and then you don't, you can't open it and you let it sit in the oven for another hour. And then you take it out of the water bath and let it room temp and then put it in the
太美味了。你做了双重烘焙吗？它真的很棒。它真的很棒。是的。嗯，你把它放进烤箱烤一个小时，然后让它烤，然后你不能打开它，让它在烤箱里再放一个小时。然后你把它从水浴中拿出来，让它室温冷却，然后放进
fridge. It's like a whole thing. Emily, if you really want to do impression, he was coming over for dinner. What would you bake with the kids? Oh, I disagree. What would it be? Is it a dinner or sweets? I'd probably make like a, I'm probably not as good at the baking.
冰箱。这真是一整套流程。艾米丽，如果你真的想给人留下深刻印象，他要来吃晚饭。你会和孩子们一起烘焙什么？哦，我不同意。会是什么？是晚餐还是甜点？我可能会做个……我可能不太擅长烘焙。
I mean, I make a fantastic roast chicken. I would make you like a good roast chicken. Yeah. I'll be over for that. Am I remembering, is John a good cook? Am I remembering that right? No, no, no. No, no, no.
我是说，我做的烤鸡非常棒。我会为你做一只好的烤鸡。是的。我会为此而去的。我记得约翰是个好厨师吗？我没记错吧？不，不，不。不，不，不。
No, no. No, he's very good at scrambled eggs and that's about it. Oh boy. What about, and if you, if you're at home and you're in Brooklyn and you're going to, you guys are going to order in takeout. Yeah. What, and you're like, fuck it. I'm going to just, I'm going to live a little tonight.
不，不。不，他非常擅长炒鸡蛋，仅此而已。哦天哪。那，如果你在家里，你在布鲁克林，你们要点外卖。是的。什么，如果你想，去他的。我今晚要好好享受一下。
What is the thing? What's the thing? We had Thai food last night. Yeah. A Patsy you just crushed a Patsy. I love a drunken noodle. I love a drunken noodle. Are you fucking kidding me?
是什么？是什么？我们昨晚吃了泰国菜。是的。帕泰，你刚吃了一份帕泰。我喜欢醉面。我喜欢醉面。你在开玩笑吗？
So good. Oh. So good. So good. There's just so much starch. It's just so much salt. That was Jason's, that was Jason's nickname in 1998. Drunken noodle.
太好吃了。哦。太好吃了。太好吃了。淀粉太多了。盐太多了。那是杰森在1998年的绰号。醉面。
Drunken noodle. Yeah. Oh, drunken noodle. Because it described, it described his state of mind and also his state of play. Browse. You know what I had for breakfast yesterday, guys? Yeah. Please let us guess, please.
醉面。是的。哦，醉面。因为它描述了，它描述了他的精神状态，也描述了他的比赛状态。浏览。你们知道我昨天早餐吃了什么吗，伙计们？是的。请让我们猜猜，请。
Fruit loops. No. A bagel. No. No. Pop rocks. Sugar smacks. No.
水果圈。不。百吉饼。不。不。跳跳糖。糖果麦片。不。
Pop rocks. I'm not kidding. Dippin' sticks and maple syrup. I love dippin' sticks. I love dippin' sticks. Let me fucking guess. I thought you said that we could guess. A tub of.
跳跳糖。我没开玩笑。蘸酱棒和枫糖浆。我喜欢蘸酱棒。我喜欢蘸酱棒。让我该死地猜猜。我以为你说我们可以猜。一桶。
Chicken and waffles. A tub of cool whip. No, I had a bowl of chili with cornbread. Oh, god damn it. It's hard for us to start the day, isn't it? How often do you redo the plumbing at the house? Are you a galvanized steel yet? Have you gotten a cease and desist from the power and water?
炸鸡华夫饼。一桶酷派奶油。不，我吃了一碗带玉米面包的辣椒。哦，该死。我们很难开始新的一天，不是吗？你多久重做一次家里的管道？你还是镀锌钢吗？你收到水电局的停止令了吗？
We have PVC pipe. Do you have your plumber and his snake equipment on retainer? His snake equipment. Emily, I apologize for today. Oh, my god. It's been the last 59 minutes. They went, Shaden Scottie just said, fuck it. And they just went straight to the source.
我们有PVC管。你有你的水管工和他的疏通设备待命吗？他的疏通设备。艾米丽，我为今天道歉。哦，天哪。这已经是过去59分钟了。他们，谢登和斯科蒂刚说，去他的。他们直接找到了源头。
They took the toilet out. They cut a hole in the floor. And they go straight into the main line. Throw a bunch of hay down there. Right into the main line. Fuck it. Fuck it. We'll do it live.
他们把马桶拆了。他们在地板上切了个洞。他们直接进入主管道。往里面扔了一堆干草。直接进入主管道。去他的。去他的。我们要现场直播。
Tap into the city. Emily Blunt, listen to me. I have been such a fan for so long. It's such a pleasure meeting you. Me too. I just think, well, first of all, I would love to see you in New York. I know.
接入城市管道。艾米丽·布朗特，听我说。我当你的粉丝很久了。见到你真是太荣幸了。我也是。我只是觉得，嗯，首先，我很想在纽约见到你。我知道。
Easy, easy, easy. Let's do like a lunch or something. I would love it because I would love to go for lunch with you because I don't want the last image of you that I have of you and your toilet habits. Like this is terrible. I know. It's a great point.
轻松点，轻松点。我们吃个午饭什么的。我很想，因为我很想和你一起吃午饭，因为我不希望我对你最后的印象是你和你的马桶习惯。这太糟糕了。我知道。这是一个很好的观点。
Well, at the very latest, we're all going to get together and go see Sean's play called Good Night Oscar playing at. Some theater in the spring. It's in New York. It's in New York in the spring. It's in the spring. So we've got time for this pinky injury. Yeah, that's why I'm telling you.
好吧，最迟，我们都会聚在一起去看肖恩的戏，叫《晚安奥斯卡》，在……春天在某个剧院上演。它在纽约。春天在纽约。在春天。所以我们有时间处理这个小指伤。是的，这就是我告诉你的原因。
There'll be something else. Believe me, reaching for the fruit loops is no guarantee of staying healthy. So true. Will knows me. He'll lacerate his hand with a spoon. We love you, Emily. Please say hi to John.
会有别的事情的。相信我，伸手去拿水果圈并不能保证保持健康。太对了。威尔了解我。他会用勺子割伤他的手。我们爱你，艾米丽。请代我向约翰问好。
Tell him to clear some time for us, please. Emily, are you guys going to be in the city in December during the holidays? So do you know what? We're not. We're about to go to Sydney, Australia for 12 weeks. I'm doing a movie out there. No.
告诉他为我们腾出点时间，拜托。艾米丽，你们十二月假期期间会在城里吗？你知道吗？我们不在。我们马上要去澳大利亚悉尼待12周。我要在那里拍一部电影。不。
Did one of you say no? No. I did. No. No. I'm the voice of Australia. Did you know that? Don't.
你们中有人说不吗？不。我说了。不。不。我是澳大利亚的代言人。你知道吗？别。
I am. Oh, my God. That's brilliant. The spokesperson for tourism Australia, not a joke. Are you really? No. When did you get that? You don't do the accent, do you?
我是。哦，天哪。那太棒了。澳大利亚旅游局的发言人，不是开玩笑。你真的是吗？不。你什么时候得到的？你不用那种口音，对吧？
No, it's me and Rose Byrne, and it just came out, and it's about telling people to go back. That's great. I swear to God. Stop it. Yeah, it's funny. Anyway. All right.
不，是我和罗斯·伯恩，它刚出来，是关于告诉人们回去。那太棒了。我发誓。别说了。是的，这很有趣。总之。好吧。
Well, it's working. I'm going to miss you guys. Oh, that sucks. You're going to miss Christmas too, Emily. You know they celebrate Christmas in the summer there. No, no, no. We don't have a hot Christmas. We have a pool party.
嗯，它奏效了。我会想念你们的。哦，那太糟糕了。你也会错过圣诞节的，艾米丽。你知道他们在那里夏天庆祝圣诞节吗？不，不，不。我们没有炎热的圣诞节。我们有泳池派对。
Literally, Jason does that to me every time. I was like, really? Yeah. I was waiting for you to go, hang on. What? Stupid Sean. No, we're going to have a hot Christmas. I'm so excited.
真的，杰森每次都那样对我。我当时想，真的吗？是的。我一直在等你问，等等。什么？笨蛋肖恩。不，我们要过一个炎热的圣诞节。我太兴奋了。
Dang it. All right. Wait, really quick. Tell me what the movie is, and tell me, like, who's in it? Directing it? Are you excited? What's going on? Very excited.
该死。好吧。等等，很快。告诉我那部电影是什么，告诉我，谁在里面？谁导演的？你兴奋吗？怎么回事？非常兴奋。
It's Brian Gosling is in it, and David Leach is directing it. It's called The Fall Guy, based on that. Holy shit. Don't you love Leach, isn't he? I love Leach. Wait, The Fall Guy based on the TV show? Based on that TV series. Do you remember that TV series?
瑞恩·高斯林在里面，大卫·雷奇在导演。它叫《特技狂人》，基于那个。天哪。你不喜欢雷奇吗，他不是……？我喜欢雷奇。等等，《特技狂人》基于那个电视剧？基于那个电视剧。你记得那个电视剧吗？
Yes, of course. I love it. Of course. So Ryan is playing The Fall Guy. He's playing the stunt guy. And it's this bonkers, mad, incredible action adventure. It's very funny. That sounds so fantastic.
是的，当然。我喜欢它。当然。所以瑞恩在演《特技狂人》。他在演那个特技演员。这是一部疯狂、疯狂、令人难以置信的动作冒险片。非常有趣。听起来太棒了。
Amazing. Amazing. Good for you. David Leach is the best. Well, keep doing, like, the greatest work in the world, and being the greatest person in the world, and we'd like to see and hear more of you in person. Emily, it's so delightful to see you. You're just something else.
太棒了。太棒了。为你高兴。大卫·雷奇是最棒的。好吧，继续做世界上最伟大的工作，做世界上最伟大的人，我们希望能亲自见到你，听到更多关于你的消息。艾米丽，见到你真是太高兴了。你真是与众不同。
I love you guys so much. Love you too. Love to John and the kids. Nice to meet you. Thank you. Lovely to meet you, Sean. Yes. Love you too.
我太爱你们了。也爱你们。代我向约翰和孩子们问好。很高兴见到你。谢谢。很高兴见到你，肖恩。是的。也爱你。
All right. See you soon. All right, dudes. Love you. Bye. Love you too. Have a great time. Bye.
好吧。回头见。好吧，伙计们。爱你们。再见。也爱你。玩得开心。再见。
Man. Right? She's just so great. I've been such a fan for so long. Me too. I love her. I can't believe you guys haven't met. Anyway.
天哪。对吧？她真是太棒了。我当她的粉丝很久了。我也是。我爱她。我不敢相信你们还没见过面。总之。
I know John, but it was... You would love her, Sean. It was BE before Emily. I think we've got a serious situation with John. I don't know how that has gotten away from us. And now it's too late. It's on me. It's bad.
我认识约翰，但那是……你会爱上她的，肖恩。那是艾米丽之前的BE。我觉得我们和约翰之间的情况很严重。我不知道那是怎么从我们手中溜走的。现在太晚了。是我的错。很糟糕。
It's on me. I feel like I have been sort of clearing out a little bit and not wanting to take that from you because you knew him before me. I know. That's going to be my excuse, which is pretty true. I got to get it. I got to get it.
是我的错。我觉得我一直在清理一些东西，不想从你那里拿走那个，因为你在我之前就认识他。我知道。那将是我的借口，这很真实。我得得到它。我得得到它。
You're a terrible friend, Will. Well, that's true. But I'm so glad you brought up the edge of tomorrow. It's like one of my... That's so good. Jay, I'm serious. I'm really serious. You're going to be blown away by how good it is.
你是个糟糕的朋友，威尔。嗯，那是真的。但我很高兴你提到了《明日边缘》。那是我的……之一。太棒了。杰，我是认真的。我是真的。你会对它有多好感到震惊的。
And I think, was that the same director? Joe Kaczynski, I want to say? Who did Top Gun, I want to say? Or Doug Liman. Doug Liman was edge of tomorrow? I think that's right. I think it was Doug Liman. I'll look it up right now.
而且我想，那是同一个导演吗？乔·卡辛斯基，我想说？谁拍了《壮志凌云》，我想说？还是道格·里曼。道格·里曼是《明日边缘》的导演？我想是对的。我想是道格·里曼。我现在就查一下。
Yeah. It was Doug Liman. Tom Cruise did another great film with Joe Kaczynski, though, I think. Anyway. Doug Liman also did the first born movie. He's done a lot of... Very quietly did a bunch of big movies
是的。是道格·里曼。不过汤姆·克鲁斯和乔·卡辛斯基拍了另一部伟大的电影，我想。总之。道格·里曼也拍了第一部《谍影重重》。他拍了很多……非常安静地拍了一堆大电影，
that were real kind of game changers. That Edge of Tomorrow, Jason, you... I mean, we've spent most of this show time on Edge of Tomorrow. I know. But it is one of the more underrated movies of the last 30 years. For sure.
它们确实是某种游戏规则改变者。那部《明日边缘》，杰森，你……我是说，我们在这部节目里大部分时间都在谈论《明日边缘》。我知道。但它是过去30年里最被低估的电影之一。肯定的。
And Tom's actually funny in it. It's like a comic... Everything about it is so good. It's really well made. I'm on it. But I love that Emily. But that Emily, what a... She really is the real life Mary Poppins.
而且汤姆在里面其实很有趣。这就像一部喜剧……关于它的一切都太好了。它制作得非常好。我同意。但我喜欢那个艾米丽。但那个艾米丽，真是个……她真的是现实生活中的玛丽·波平斯。
No, she's something else, man. Yeah, she's just a great friend. And I meant it when I... We should have gone further on that answer about how what's the secret sauce to her being so goddamn affable and personable and genuine. Yeah, well, it's what you always say.
不，她真是与众不同，伙计。是的，她只是个伟大的朋友。我是认真的，当……我们应该在那个关于她为什么如此该死地和蔼可亲、平易近人、真诚的秘诀是什么的回答上走得更远。是的，嗯，这是你一直说的。
It's the sexy indifference. Well, but yeah. But for her, it's not put on. She doesn't do it. She's very comfortable. She's confident. Her mom and dad are really nice. She comes from a normal place.
那是性感的冷漠。嗯，但是是的。但对她来说，这不是装出来的。她不那样做。她很舒服。她很自信。她的父母真的很好。她来自一个正常的地方。
She had a... And I think that that lays the base for being a very sort of normal, comfortable person. She's not insecure. Everybody's got their regular stuff as human beings. But it's not like she's not doing it out of a place of pain or whatever. She's doing it all because she loves to do it
她有一个……而且我认为这为成为一个非常正常、舒服的人奠定了基础。她不自卑。每个人作为人类都有自己的常规东西。但这不像她是因为痛苦或什么而那样做。她做这一切是因为她喜欢做，
and she's a good person. She's very, very down to earth as you guys know. And I feel like that's just the way she wants to be and would be like that with or without fame and success. And she and John are great together. They're very good sort of yin-yang too. They work off each other very well. And I joke about John's enthusiasm in the best way
而且她是个好人。她非常、非常脚踏实地，正如你们所知。我觉得这就是她想要的方式，无论有没有名气和成功，她都会是那样。她和约翰在一起很好。他们也是很好的阴阳结合。他们配合得很好。我开玩笑说约翰的热情是最好的方式，
because I love him. He's like a puppy. I always describe him. He's like a big... Well, because they fell in respect. They didn't fall in love. They fell in respect. Holy fuck.
因为我爱他。他就像一只小狗。我总是形容他。他就像一只大……嗯，因为他们陷入了尊重。他们没有坠入爱河。他们陷入了尊重。该死。
So listen, but... I just can't believe you tattooed that to the small. You're back. It's just... That's excessive. Aren't you excited about her new movie called What's It Called Again? What's It Called?
所以听着，但是……我简直不敢相信你把它纹在了小地方。你回来了。这只是……那太过分了。你不为她的新电影感到兴奋吗，叫什么来着？叫什么？
The Fall... Guy! Everybody! You can't say guy. By the way, why do you go... Yeah, but it's... Guy's not by. But why do you always go up?
《特技狂人》！大家！你不能说狂人。顺便说一句，你为什么要去……是的，但是它是……狂人不是……但你为什么总是往上走？
Why are you yelling? And why does it always go high? And then you repeat it? And you repeat it? Like, how did that become what it is? Because... Yeah. Like you make it worse.
你为什么在喊？为什么它总是变高？然后你重复它？你重复它？就像，那怎么变成了现在这样？因为……是的。就像你让它变得更糟。
You know what? I've decided that for all these... I mean, first of all, stop pumping the air. And you can't say guy. What you need to do if you're worried about having a sign off, you always have to have one in your pocket on stand. Yeah!
你知道吗？我决定，对于所有这些……我是说，首先，停止在空中泵气。你不能说狂人。如果你担心有一个结束语，你需要做的是，你必须在口袋里准备一个备用的。是的！
Nailed it! Smart. Wise. Smart. Wise. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco,
说得好！聪明。睿智。聪明。睿智。SmartLess是由Rob Armjurf、Bennett Barbaco和Michael Grant Terry 100%有机且手工制作的。
and Michael Grant Terry. SmartLess. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus
SmartLess。我们的下一集将在下周发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Wondry Plus在苹果播客或Wondry应用程序上提前收听且无广告。
in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。